recently
the u.s engaged in peace talks with
china
and it seems like they're not going too
well because the ap is reporting
it's unusual the level of bickering
and a smackdown that's been going on
back and forth the u.s criticizes china
over a lot of things they're doing
china criticizes back but china is
accusing the u.s i kid you not of
slaughtering black people exploiting the
black lives matter and woke narrative
to criticize the u.s when the u.s tries
calling out
the concentration camps and other things
other than that china's been saying that
in the u.s
we have we have no grounds to complain
about democracy over there because the
people in the us don't even agree with
you american democracy either
and the whole thing seems to be well
highly unusual they say but shocking to
a lot of people because
among many conservatives they believe
china would never speak like this
if donald trump was still president i
think maybe it's just escalation whether
it was trump or
biden there's been an ongoing escalating
tension between
you know the two countries but in terms
of china calling the u.s weak and they
did
we got this video of joe biden nearly
falling down the stairs which is getting
a lot of attention now binding saying it
was just the wind it was the wind
but a lot of people are questioning
whether or not joe biden has the mental
and physical fitness to be president a
new poll shows 33 percent of americans
believe he does not
so we're gonna talk about this we'll
talk about some other stuff i guess
there's like a woke monopoly coming out
which will be fun to talk about
we're hanging out with the uh the
creator of the infamous
the list suraj you want to introduce
yourself
what's going on tim uh siraj hashmi uh
now formerly employee of the washington
examiner
uh i am a free agent and creator of the
list but
you can also check me out on habibi bros
that is the podcast that me
and mujahid kobe my buddy jay who has
been banned
12 different times by twitter and
constantly comes back he is the man who
cannot be killed on twitter
should he go on the list oh well that's
the thing is the list only works for him
and i never put him on it there you go
so so explain the list real quick all
right so the list is literally
uh a power ranking of people who need
their phones taken away so for example
if someone tweets something a genuinely
bad
take you know it could be comparing say
trump to hitler
although that is actually very trite and
commonplace but something
for example uh you know the chinese
communist party tweets out something
insane about the united states knowing
obviously how hypocritical it is they'll
go on the list for
it yeah yeah and then there's people
like should i name anybody specifically
were just talking about jennifer rubin
washington post right washington post
the formerly i guess conservative
blogger pro establishment but basically
she has gone on
uh i i can tell you basically one of the
tweets that got her on the list was so
benign but it was it's so ridiculous
uh she posted the photo of her dog and
saying sleeping in during the biden area
yes
we sleep in on the weekends when was
bombing yeah
it was literally like the day or two
after that yeah yeah yeah yeah on the
list
right on all right so so we'll uh we'll
get into it yeah we got innis what's up
everybody ian crossland how's it going
great to be here i love you and me sour
patch lids in the corner
all right before we get started ladies
and gentlemen we have a really awesome
sponsor
i've been talking a lot about how we
need decentralized
social media and our sponsor today is
pocketnet go to pocketnet.app you can
see the link in the description below
become a member it is a truly fully
decentralized network pocketnet says no
corporation
open source nobody can take your
subscribers away
all advertising revenue goes directly to
you as a content creator
owned and self-policed by users like you
again pocketnet.app the reason i think
this is great
i'm stoked that these uh that pocketnet
is sponsoring the show is one thing we
keep talking about
is some kind of open source code anybody
can use to have their own decentralized
social media platform or website
that way we can't get banned anymore now
maybe they'll still come after your
infrastructure maybe you start your own
website
but this is one way to guarantee that
doesn't happen
there are a lot of different uh social
media sites but pocket net seems to be
the first and only truly decentralized
so again really really uh grateful for
their sponsorship you guys can go to
pocketnet.app sign up
and uh i guess nobody can ban you so
you know for better or for worse we
believe in free speech when you're there
i guess you're going to have all the
free speech in the world
also don't forget go to timcast.com
become a member to get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
show
we had curt schlichter the other day
talking about rand paul and dr fauci
we had you know jack murphy we're
talking about joe biden in that weird
cgi video that wasn't really cgi we
debunked that and of course
lieutenant colonel alan west was on the
show so if you want to get those
exclusive segments
go to timcast.com become a member don't
forget to like share subscribe this show
and let's get into the first story this
is the craziest thing to me
you know let me just read the news first
the u.s sun
reports tense clash china accuses u.s
of slaughtering black people and says
americans have little faith in democracy
as talk tensions flare they said the two
nations met face to face in anchorage
alaska on thursday evening
for the first time since president joe
biden took office but any hopes that
bilateral relations could be reset
after years of trade wars and tensions
over cyber security
during trump's presidency were quickly
stamped out u.s secretary of state
anthony
anthony blinken and national security
adviser jake sullivan
opened opening the meeting by referring
to concerns over beijing's human rights
record
china's top foreign affairs official
yang jiechi thunderously responded
by accusing the u.s of its own human
rights violations saying
we hope the u.s will do better on human
rights yang said during a 15-minute
speech
the fact is that there are many problems
in the u.s regarding human rights
which is admitted by the us itself yang
added
that human rights issues in the us just
racism were deep seated
they did not just emerge over the past
four years such as black lives matter
this is really annoying to me because
the narrative for the most part from
black lives matter is over hyped
exaggerated and just
i'm going to say it not true i don't
know if uh you
i think you you may have seen this ian
but did you see the the poll
where they asked liberals and
conservatives
how many innocent you know or how many
black people were killed by police in
2019
and liberals said over a thousand and
the actual number is 27.
so what's happening is what yeah we have
this median narrative
this big lie where they keep saying
these things over and over again
and you get these people who genuinely
believe that cops are going around
hunting down black people if i thought
that was true i'd be out there with
black lives matter every single day
but we know it's not true any death
caused by the cops
it's it's a tragedy either it you know
kappa was defending himself it's still a
tragedy or the cop was committing a
crime
especially a tragedy now china is
exploiting this
our own media is tearing our country
apart in my opinion
and now china's accusing us of being
weak yeah it's it's kind of interesting
you know china obviously can't look in
the mirror and never call out their own
sins
for example obviously just how
oppressive they are to their own people
the re-education camps of uyghurs the
lack you know basically the
the hong kong and threatening their
autonomy
uh and jailing basically any political
dissident so they have no obviously no
moral standing on this issue
i just find it hilarious that they think
that
the us government is sanctioning like
basically
all this terrorism against uh one
you know racial demographic i don't
think they they believe it
no i mean like they i mean but they're
accusing us of this i think i think
it's really interesting in previous
administrations would china have
stood up so brazenly and insulted
degraded the united states to their
faces
nope the iron wasn't hot enough but but
you know what i think
i mean if you remember under the obama
administration and
the the plane situation the plane uh
confrontation and they basically made
them almost i think it was like
they wouldn't let them land or get off
the plane they basically had to oh wow
yeah this is so this is how this
happened on the obama administration i
don't know if this is something
that you know it was an almost an
international incident that had to get
stamped out quickly
because china they ramped up the
aggression against uh
you know foreign diplomats or i guess
u.s diplomats in this case
um and then you have the whole anal
swaps thing oh yeah yeah
u.s diplomats entering the country and
they had to get a coveted test by well
so
we'll jump to that one in a second but
the point i want to make is
as the tensions escalate as u.s
uh power wanes internationally and and
other countries are losing confidence in
whether or not the united states could
even defend a place like taiwan or the
south china sea
china is getting more and more brazen
they know the narrative's not true
they don't care they're putting on a
show for the people of the world to say
we're not scared of america anymore and
we're going to stand up
and we're going to use their own
fracturing of their of their culture
against them
that's what's happening now as for the
uh the butt swabs thing which was like a
huge story
i think it's fair to say if donald trump
was president that would not have
happened
yeah that's fair to say but i also and
we were talking about this i don't think
under the trump administration they
would sen they willing
they would willingly send out a group of
diplomats
to china in the middle of a trade war
right
and basically subject themselves to
something like this i mean
during the trade war negotiations for
the first trade deal that they
uh agreed to all the negotiations
happened in washington dc literally
across the from the
eisenhower executive office building
which is the white house um
but they're sending diplomats to china
for what routine work
i don't know i mean we had an ambassador
to the we had the u.s ambassador to
china
and we still have diplomatic relations
with them but
you know there is no reason
to subject our own diplomats to that
it's
it's
just an embarrassment it's amazing for
those that aren't familiar uh u.s
diplomats were
forcefully anal swabbed by china yeah
and i think that's another another sign
of just
attempting to humiliate the united
states for forceful swabbing of the bums
of american personnel
and they're basically look at this
meeting
it was 15 minutes of of the chinese
you know officials yelling at america
and the americans just sat there and
took
it saber-rattling so i just wanted to
point out
that the whole confrontation with the
obama administration
uh so the u.s military always sends out
a set of rolling air stairs
um on every single uh presidential trip
and so they have to seek chinese
approval to use the equipment
and when president obama arrived in
china
the chinese reversed their position they
wouldn't let them get off the plane wow
yeah so it's like
a tactic yeah but was was obama supposed
to be there
yeah it was i think it was actually a
supposed to be a official
presidential visit to me so the
president
so this wouldn't have happened under
trump is that would you think it's fair
to say
well it didn't happen under trump
because when he went to china
he got like a huge welcoming uh ceremony
i mean
i mean i people don't people remember
obviously his
his uh meeting with kim jong-un and uh
in vietnam
uh in singapore um i think it was just
singapore they had at least two meetings
if i'm not mistaken um but when he went
to china
there was a huge ceremony there was a
huge like celebration
of the us president going to china and
if you remember
correctly president xi and president
trump
actually had like deep affection for one
another but
at the same time trump was telling
everybody here in the united states like
obviously we're going to be implementing
all these tariffs on china
uh yeah a lot of tough talk but and this
is where he gets the criticism for being
you know cozying up to authoritarians
because of
how he approaches them now his
actual rhetoric is different from the
actual policy because the policy was
good
even if the rhetoric didn't match it and
that's i think that's what people
constantly get at trump for
but he was particularly strong on china
and biden is particularly weak on china
could it have been that fanfare in that
celebration was because they were scared
of trump
trump that's possible look man trump is
an erratic hey
hey we're still number one baby i
i look at it like this even people like
even trump supporters recognize that
trump is kind of
you know erratic i guess is the right
way to put it meaning like
he just says do it get it done come it
pops into his head he says do it
so if he gets mad on a whim he could be
like shut it down no no deal for you
so china knows these this trade war is
on yeah the tariffs are are a legit
problem for them
so they start kissing his ass yeah i
think the chinese communist party is a
glass cannon
in in that they're very fragile from
what i've been discerning from our
guests in the last few weeks
they're they're on the verge of collapse
but they don't want to show it and if
they sense weakness they're going to go
and bite it because they can hit
hard from a distance but if if they get
attacked they got a real problem
and biden is not an attacker i i don't i
don't physically
i don't think the chinese communist
party is particularly weak i think
they're still
on the rise i think it is what's
changing though is the
sort of the the
what's the best word i could probably
put it on um
sort of the image the the there was a
fallacy that russia was somehow the most
dangerous country in the world and that
was our geopolitical foe and threat
and they hijacked an election and
basically installed trump as
you know putin's you know lap dog like
you know as crazy as the
you know that that blue a non-talk um
but then everybody just ignored china
and now we're realizing everything
that's happening there you have the
uyghur re-education camps you have
uh hong kong autonomy withering away you
have
the oppression of basically everyone uh
and their political dissidence
they have the belts and road initiative
which boss basically it mortgages the
future of basically every single country
abroad
that china does business with
particularly in africa
they build up their infrastructure in
exchange for
uh so like they'll give say a country
like you know mozambique or or
you know name your country in africa
uh you know billion dollar loans
but we get to control your ports it
sounds they have to pay back that loan
sounds like they're just placing the imf
yeah that's the economic hitman strategy
right
and so they get all this economic
control over these countries
and they get to gain access to their
valuable resources whatever mining
uh whatever you know grain you name it
farming
and uh yeah they just consolidate that
power
and the reason why they're still on the
come up is and this
obviously is tied into the political
oppression is that when you only have
one single thought
you can get a lot more done i think bill
maher was talking about it as well as
tucker carlson
interestingly enough in the same week
about how china is particularly strong
in their military
because they just focus on the job and
just get it done
and i think bill maher's criticism in
particular wasn't praiseworthy of
of the chinese communist party but
really highlighting how
they because they're so authoritarian
they can get more done
and we are so democratic we can get
nothing done
and it's just democratic is one way to
put it i think what we're seeing is
our values were exploited sowing
division
and this this western imperialism of
sorts whatever you want to call it
where we have like the international
monetary fund where we have the un and
nato
the united states and their military
bases everywhere it's it's falling apart
like you're mentioning was it was the
the belt and belt and road initiative
yeah so china is
essentially giving loans building up
infrastructure in these countries
to then have massive debt that will give
them economic control
that's what the the western powers used
to do yeah or
still probably do well that's what
that's what colonialism was based on
it was it may not have been as say
concrete as what the belt and road
initiative is but it was basically
controlling territories to gain access
to the resources
in exchange for say example like french
colonialism
french colonialism was basically uh
we're gonna exchange
uh whatever you got and we're gonna give
you french culture because that's like
you know that's we're superior to your
inferiority what we are seeing
is china engaging in neocolonialism
it's effectively just colonialism but
you know it's in you know
from history till now they're starting
up a new process transactional
well but it's not just that it's chinese
immigrants so
china's a crowded nation they are seeing
a lot of you know the creation of a lot
of wealth as they expand
they then naturally want to move to
other countries to find opportunity
and to find more space i actually uh
interestingly enough about the belt and
road initiative is that they don't even
hire locally
they bring in their own workers from
china to build up these
you know whatever level of
infrastructure roads bridges
buildings you name it tunnels it's all
that doesn't stimulate the local economy
all it does is just
uh put these countries into debt and
that's right make them beholden to the
chinese communist parties
isn't that what the imf would do
basically yeah so
so listen china is absolutely displacing
the western
strategies and and foreign policy and
they're sending in chinese workers a lot
of countries
many people who are just regular old
citizens citizens of china are naturally
just
immigrating other countries there's no
plan there they're just doing it because
they want to move they want to find a
place then you end up with lots of
chinese immigrants and other countries
setting up their own little communities
in chinatowns and things like that
then you get the belt and road
initiative which creates the economic
power structure
eventually you're gonna have many
countries which are just going to be
like second world satellites of china if
not they already are
and the us people don't seem to realize
this we you know we we talked about this
i think earlier in the week that
manufacturing in the in the us actually
is
up a little bit like one point something
percent year over
year but we don't produce all that much
relative to many other countries our
principal export is
the us dollar for for buying oil so we
prop up the petro dollar
with the threat of war to anybody who
dares drop that dollar
the us is in is in a crumble is in a
very difficult
position it's you know we've got joe
biden who apparently is struggling to
walk up these stairs the wind blew him
over i kid you not they said the wind
blew him over i mean that was not a good
excuse they could've said he tripped and
that we could have moved on
but joe biden falls over so the wind
blew him over wow you've got hyper
polarization
you've got a 50 50 split basically in
our government senate is 50 50
and then the house is like 219 to 211 or
whatever like
just as narrow as it can get they're
trying to remove some dem
uh uh they're trying to remove a
republican who is duly elected and
certified to
it's just it's falling apart our
international systems are failing
the international wars have failed our
our way of controlling other countries
is falling apart and china is assuming
all of it
and i have to wonder how many special
interests
millionaires billionaires and
corporations in the us have already seen
that happening
and are moving their businesses over
that's back to their best exactly that's
been right
nba for instance yeah no it's been
happening for a while disney
um apple yeah i mean manufacturing and i
mean
manufacturing in china is really cheap
especially when they use weaker slave
labor right
right so uh well but i'm thinking about
it this way if the u.s dollar does
crumble
bitcoins at 58 700 or whatever yeah
these companies have already moved to
china and they're already like you got
mark cuban defending
china what what is what does he see that
is he is he hedging his back basically
saying he thinks china is going to win
this one
china's already won that's actually what
i wanted to say is that
bill maher uh interestingly enough and i
agree with him on a lot of points even
if he
even if he didn't get everything right
in his his little monologue from from
last week
he pointed out how china already won
yeah they're not they're not winning
they already won
because the the fact that we're still
bickering over things like the culture
war cancel culture you name it
you know these are things that are so
they're distractions to the bigger
picture
and in terms of global influence you
know the united states
are you know we you know that i saw a
t-shirt once that said word number one
but there was no apostrophe in it
[Laughter]
we're number number one yeah yeah
and so like you know while the united
states economy still is number one in
the world as
i said we're still we're number one baby
i mean that is that's those days
number one it's like the patriots
dynasty ending i never really got into
the whole like we're the best
thing because like when you're at the
top you're just a target people want to
rip you down we should be part of an
integral group of allies
that are working we were though yeah we
really should like russia and
britain and england well not russia but
we
we did have western trade alliances nato
the u.n
yeah and that power structure is failing
i mean look the coalition that went into
libya was it like france
you know the us a couple other countries
i guess look at the coalition of the
willing or whatever going to iraq
it wasn't just the us it was a bunch of
different countries
expressing this you know control i mean
we they they well
after 9 11 there was uh they invoked
article 5 of of nato
getting uh us to the point where we had
every nato nation as well as we got uh
australia and new zealand uh involved in
and uh in a basically the invasion of
afghanistan which then turned into the
invasion of iraq
i mean it's just it for some reason
uh the united states loves war we're
never going to get out of it and that
has depleted our economy
tremendously and if you ever want to
talk about how climate change impacts it
you know it doesn't help it
you guys ever hear the non-aligned
movement no it's basically the united
nate the other united
nations on earth there's the united
nations that we know of and then all the
countries that aren't involved with it
are in this
united group of nations called the
non-aligned movement who's not
who's in it iran is the that is where
they're headquartered was in iran for a
while um
uh was like the chairman of it um
yeah thank you for pronouncing that
properly
and i would pull the list there's like
92 countries or something some insane
number and don't quote me on that number
but
it's all these countries that the united
states is basically doesn't want to have
diplomatic ties with these are the
people we need to be allied with
yeah well there's also bricks the brics
nations i mean
[Music]
that's the thing is like so
iran and the united states are
their interests are diametric
diametrically opposed you know iran
wants basically hegemony over the region
the united states
uh i mean the iranian regime
has been on the path of terror for quite
some time funneling
money to hamas hezbollah uh
you name it i mean they've been killing
our guys and our men and women overseas
um i don't imagine that's gonna happen
anytime soon unless of course
president biden tries to get the iran
nuclear deal going on again
uh god help us if that happens but um
look i am i am fine with like making
friends with other countries
so long as it doesn't isn't to our
detriment we're not being taken
advantage of
and i don't think that the iranian
regime is would be acting in good
faith i'm looking at like china like the
nazi party and
if we had allied with russia before the
nazis invaded poland
we could have possibly prevented it what
do you mean
well because we weren't really on good
terms with russia before the war
russia wouldn't come to france's aid
about world war ii yeah
okay and so this is like a modern day
like we're on the cusp of another world
war
with another you know racist ethno state
right and unless we ally now with russia
and india
and iran and all of these countries
around china if they're going to do some
crazy
well the thing is like china and iran
are basically in bed with each other
because i mean when iran doesn't have
you know any of its allies to go to if
it doesn't have the united states to go
to
say funnel them cash they'll go to
russia and they'll go to china
because china definitely wants to have
them on their side yeah
anyone who's an enemy of the united
states is their friend so
and like we're talking about it's it's
china doing everything in their power to
expand their influence to
anyone who's willing to listen and i
think that
i wonder if there's elements of the us
that are worried about war
so they're already essentially resigning
to the fact that we will lose
i think it was uh uh we're talking with
kurt he said there's war games
that the us has done with china and all
of these war games we just lose lose
lose
i i can only imagine there's a lot of
really rich people who are probably like
all right well if that's inevitable
i'm gonna move my money over i'm gonna
move my money to china and focus on that
business
and then in 50 years when this whole
system in the west falls apart
china will be the dominant superpower
and you will have a
an authoritarian ethno state exerting
their cultural influence over all the
other countries on the planet i would
argue obviously and i don't know if i
said this before but
it sounds like i'm repeating myself then
i apologize but i think
uh richard nixon's greatest mistake was
not anything to do with watergate it
actually had to do with opening or
opening the united states to china
because we for some reason i don't know
what miscalculation took place but it
was a miscalculation
and i was assuming that the chinese
communist party which at that time had
only existed for about
about 20 21 years after the the chinese
civil war
after world war ii that
by introducing capitalism to them they
would somehow modernize
and what they did is they basically
adapted they kept their system in place
and they basically turned their society
into
a pseudo capitalist one that encouraged
commerce and encouraged
other other you know corporations from
other countries namely from the united
states to come to them
you know get cheap manufacturing build
their their
products and then ship it across the
globe and
they did it by consolidating as much
power as they needed to
and by they i mean the chinese communist
party and
we're basically at a loss we
underestimated china
100 we we thought money and greed would
win out and we underestimated the
resolve
and the ideology and the power of the
chinese communist party
so we were hoping that our money was
going to go in
and that essentially greed necessarily
greed but like commerce and a better
life
would open up the eyes of these people
and they would say oh we should we
should do that because it'll make us
money
and then eventually that would weaken
the the power structure in the communist
party
they didn't realize how hardened it was
so what ended up happening was
the communist party exploited all those
systems around it to become even more
powerful
yeah and it we just fed the beast we
also underscore
and probably we we discount the
confucius institutes here in the united
states yeah that's a very
it's it is a very real problem but not
one that's discussed very often
and that is how a number of different
universities in the united states
have these institutes called confucius
institutes
and what they do is that they basically
it's like exporting the ideas of the
chinese communist party to
you know you know malleable minds here
in the united states
um but also you know you can look at the
chinese exchange students who come to
the united states
and i'm not saying that them coming here
is bad but what
ends up happening is they start to adapt
or they start to adopt some you know
values that we here in america embrace
they start to get you know maybe think
that like american values are actually
much
better than chinese values and they
correct that issue right away
that they have like sort of a
self-policing system and so if any
if any exchange student gets out of line
you know
they're gone yeah i think
man it's like we're on that we're on the
we're on the back end of that bell curve
it's the golden age is
is is over for us it's been we've been
in the real guys
yeah it's been fun by bitcoin
uh no no no no financial advice
i'm buying bitcoin buy gamestop
i actually don't buy it no china bought
a bunch of bitcoin a lot of bitcoin oh
yeah
so i wonder why it's skyrocketing
they've got
the spy the chinese spy that was dating
the guy the
eric swalwell swallowed yeah well that
wasn't confirmed that they were dating
or they were they were
an item for it wasn't even confirmed
that they were an item
she was just helping with like
fundraisers for a long time right
yeah i mean she had been around helping
people with fundraising here in the
in washington dc and i wouldn't say here
because we're not in washington dc
that's where i live but
um but basically when it comes to
i believe her name is fang fang and uh
or christine thing i think that's
sorry i apologize we had china
uncensored on the show and so we got the
correct parenthesis oh
nice nice um so fong fung
she had basically embedded herself as a
uh sort of like a
i guess not like a money roller like
basically someone who would a cash
bundler
yeah that's the best way of putting it
someone who would raise money um for
different political causes
and uh then somehow in the
throughout the running of it all eric
swallow was brief that she's actually a
chinese spy
and uh then he basically had to several
contact with her but now
this just happened uh mccarthy has tried
to remove swalwell from the intel
committee
over the chinese spy story so this is
just from the other day oh wow i believe
it did fail though they said the
resolution
will not likely pass in a democratic
controlled house think about how insane
this is
this dude was being helped a democrat by
a chinese spy
and they're they're keeping him on the
intel committee it's like okay let him
stay in office
but don't give him access to intel
reports they don't care
they really don't care that's why i'm
saying man i wonder how many of these
people are in on the take
they know what's coming and they're like
many of them got to butter my bread you
know how many more spies are there
that's one that we found out
and now we know that the institutions
have been infiltrated by the
basically by the concepts of of this you
know what 80-year plan that yuri
besmanov talked about it other other
people was like
they've been in here trying to divide us
and now they're calling it out
yeah because they're planned they're
basically activating the plan well we do
know that um there was a chinese spy
that worked in senator dianne
feinstein's office
um driver i think so
um i have to confirm that so this is uh
yeah this is from back in august of
2018.
details surface about senator feinstein
and the chinese spy who worked for her
that's crazy yeah i'm pretty sure it was
a driver for her
yeah and uh it's not the first time
we've been infiltrated man i mean mike
pompeo was saying it earlier last year
about a year ago he said we've been
infiltrated at every single level
you name it yeah i mean it's it's not
surprising
at all i mean as you said when you're
number one
everyone has a target on your back every
basically every other country
if we're playing mario kart we're in
first place every country has a blue
shell
yeah yeah 100 well you know essentially
we were in first place i wonder
if slash when china does overtake us
maybe they already did and they're just
not going to let us know
you know what i mean why would they let
us know if they could stay in if they
could stay in our ranks forever
i mean and and focus on them and also
not to mention think of the people who
are actually
and not and this is something that
people you know think oh just because
you know the chinese they have to be
despite think about all the non-chinese
spies that there are
i mean they they they are they are spies
for the chinese government but they're
not right they're not
chinese but no but but also think about
when when coveted first started
and they they lied to the who and then
the who ended up lying to the world
china ordered chinese citizens in
various countries to buy
personal protective equipment and ship
it back to china so they could use it
during the pandemics while they were
lying to us saying everything's fine
don't worry about it they were
they were instructing their citizens
they're these people weren't spies they
were just people who were living in
other countries for school or for
whatever reason
working at the behest of the chinese
communist party and it makes me think
of civilization the game have you ever
played that it's been a while cool game
um and i think the chinese have
overtaken us militarily
but not culturally not scientifically i
don't think
no they stole all our intellectuals yeah
they steal they basically are trying to
steal to keep up
um so they have overtaken us in some
ways
definitely militarily yeah they're
they're what's that thing worth a
thousand talents program where they're
buying up these these college professors
offering them cash then professors are
lying about it getting caught and
getting arrested are you serious
yeah yeah yeah there's been a bunch of
professors now i
were secretly taking money from china
and then some of them got caught they
were not reporting this money so they
were getting grants from the us
government
and also getting money from the chinese
government and
effectively my understanding is they
were sharing this data
with the chinese party nazis think about
it if you were
alive in 1930 what side would you have
been on now you get to choose
would you will you take their money will
you take that nazi money there were a
lot of people in america who did
that's the problem is that there are too
many people who and this is
you know obviously because hindsight's
20 20 and we always look back
and think of you know if another
holocaust happened
how would we react to it i mean it is
but that's the thing is like you know
everybody thought that
and i i referenced the syrian civil war
because that seemed like
an interesting you know that was a very
bloody affair
that uh has winded down but everybody
there were there were a lot of people in
the united states clamoring for
intervention
thinking that that was a that was
basically another genocide that was
taking place
and then we have this situation here in
xinjiang with the uyghurs being
in locked up in reeducation camps we're
seeing drone footage of them
on train platforms all in jumpsuits
blindfolded
shaved heads you know hands and feet
bonded up
and that is the closest thing i have
ever seen
in my life to what we saw in the
holocaust closest thing
and i'm still afraid to compare that to
the holocaust right because of
the what that suggests and so
you can say that the you know they're
going to mother day concentration camps
that is like as far as that's to the
extent that i'll go
because there is there is these people
are being
persecuted for practicing their faith
people being persecuted for
expressing different political views uh
for people who want democracy
in hong kong and
you know all of our nothing will move
not
dark nothing no needle will move in the
right direction because all of our
amer all of the corporations that were
formerly part of the united states
have all sold their souls to china this
time
will never stand up right for it a lot
of them not all
this time the ethno authoritarians it
seems like they're going to win
it seemed like that with the nazis too
for a while when they invaded france and
took
took control of france it was like this
is it man the british winston churchill
would just tell people
we're going to survive we're going to
get through this he didn't know he was
just gathered
up for sure china china's not stupid
enough to just
storm the borders of india necessarily i
mean the conflict happening on the
border with india is that
what was it they were fighting with
sticks and stones yeah because they know
there's going to be fighting but they
they know what propaganda is they know
information warfare works and they know
what will happen if the
of all people of the world demand
conflict it's bad enough to get the
concentration camps
but a lot of people still will be like
we're not going to do war it would wipe
out the planet
if they if they stormed into india with
guns and took
took land then everyone would freak out
and say it's happening
it's happening anyway yeah we got to
stop it from happening so they know
better
they're going to infiltrate it's going
to be cyber attacks it's going to be
political warfare
like uh who was talking about political
warfare was that uh
james was that you had some great guests
on this list what was it kurt i don't
know
a lot of great people talking about
political warfare and that yeah i think
it was james
i think so and we're not prepared for it
we
they're they're they know you gotta you
gotta be very careful about how people
view you and that's why i think when we
see these these chinese you know
officials
yelling at the us in iran for 15 minutes
saying that the u.s is slaughtering
black people they know what they're
doing
they're trying to show the world they
can make god bleed
because then there will be blood in the
water and the sharks will come yeah i
mean
so eddie izzard the comedian um
i although i think i think that's the
former name i apologize if i'm
getting it wrong right yeah yeah i saw
that recently no but
wears dresses from time to time yeah
yeah justice in dragon ball that might
be
marathon that might be the dead name oh
really did you change his name
i think so no i saw him recently and
he's still amazing
he still goes back or she goes by i
apologize i think he was either he or
she
dresser but was not transgender anyways
yes said something that was really
prescient
at the time um and it was it was sort of
like
analyzing history and how you know the
biggest uh
the biggest mistake that hitler made was
not you know anything he had to do
within germany
those invading other countries you know
because you have mao zedong
killed probably most people any other
dictator yeah joseph stalin
uh yeah pol pot you know a number of
different dictators
the key the key theme for them and the
reason they were able to stay in power
is that they never invaded any other
countries yep
and so china came close to it when uh
you had the korean war
and they were basically trying to impose
uh
communism in in the korean peninsula of
course the united states fought back
on it went to stalemate now you have
north korea and now you have china
invading many other countries with the
belt and road initiative exactly
exactly culturally look you can't
we talk about this all the time fourth
and fifth generation of warfare
what what is the purpose of war you want
to gain control of resources and
territory
right or you want to stop a threat maybe
it's preemptive war but usually it's
about gaining access to a resource and
certain territory some advantage for
your country
now how are you going to do that you're
going to march in with guns and force
people at gunpoint well that creates
resistance and opposition
right people say no to that or you say
ian i'm going to lend you 100 bucks so
you can go get that that nice new suit
you wanted thanks dude and then we're
going to put compounded interest on it
so just don't worry sign here
and then what happens a week goes by and
i go where's that ten thousand dollars
yo me buddy
and you're like whoa whoa ten thousand
like yeah read the deal
jimmy break his legs
the game can i borrow another ten
thousand they go
they're going to these people and
they're basically they're going to these
countries and saying
if you sell your country to me with this
deal
you will live like the king of kings and
then when you're dead
we'll take your country it's a win-win
isn't it and a lot of these people are
like works for me
the country will improve the lives of my
people will improve and then in 50 years
china will be in charge with exercising
debt and control over our country
sure whatever short-term gain long-term
losses
they are invading but they're doing it
smart this time they learn from us the
economic hitmen which is
kind of out of this playbook they would
do that they would say hey we're going
to give you a big loan
try and buy you out and if the people
refused then they would try and
assassinate the leader
and if they couldn't get to the guy then
they would declare all-out war
um it seems like the chinese aren't
trying step two
at all they're like they're very light
about this
slow long bribery they play the long
game
but but listen definitely the you only
need step one
when they go to one country and say
we're going to give you all this money
to help you with your infrastructure
and that country says no they go okay
well then we'll give it to your neighbor
good luck surviving and they'll go wait
wait wait
that's that's the end of the game people
know that uh
in these countries they might have
pressure where it's like we've got
conflict with these different groups
with these different tribes with these
different
countries governments and so if china
starts arming and building up their
infrastructure how long will you last
that's how it's going to play out and
now you can see
with these chinese officials basically
making a mockery of the us saying you
you're not coming from
they literally said it is wrong to say
you're coming from from a position of
strength
people in your own country don't trust
your own democracy you're slaughtering
black people
they smack down the u.s for 15 minutes
and what do we do we fight we have flame
wars we have culture wars
we are a silly people i think i think
the u.s
is facing some kind of fracturing
but a lot of people talk about a
peaceful divorce i think we've already
broken apart
you know i talked about this before
right joe biden comes out and says you
know we
come on man you know we need new
restrictions for govind and texas and
florida are like nah
if if you don't have red states
trusting the president and agreeing to
work together towards a common goal then
then the president just represents the
blue states maybe maybe they're look i'm
i'm a young guy i guess
young enough maybe there were periods in
american history
where states half the states were saying
no to the president maybe
maybe that was 100 some odd years ago
the last time we had a civil war right
yeah i mean i don't i don't think we're
going to civil war
it's not going to be what you think it
is it's not going to be civil war is
informational
right not with arms that's that's that's
exactly what i'm saying it's fourth and
fifth generational
warfare yeah so the point i'm making is
we're well past that point like china's
not going to march into india
with guns they're going to buy more and
more land they're doing it
they're buying up property in the u.s
like crazy they're buying up property in
brazil
like crazy and then their citizens
naturally just move into these areas and
then live in these places
using the existing laws they don't need
to march in with guns when they can
march with economics
same thing in the united states the
civil war we're experiencing is the
culture war it is a cold civil war
there i shouldn't even say it's cold
because people have literally been shot
and killed
you know notably in portland for
instance but it's not like factions with
armies marching towards each other
the issue is the best example is joe
biden comes out
talks about covid florida texas other
red states just look at joe biden and
say buzz off
we do not take your advice and we do not
care what you think
so you got blue state saying you got it
joe and red state's saying we don't
agree with the president
we are already split into two different
realities
you want to live like normal florida's a
waiting you go you got to wear a mask
anymore you can go shopping go to the
movies everything's back to normal go to
new york
new york is now the epicenter again and
they're saying oh no it's it's bad we
gotta do more lockdowns you go to europe
europe's locking down like crazy yeah
here in the u.s to see blue states go
the exact
opposite direction of red states no
unity at all
i do find that interesting though that i
mean like
the division has been happening for a
while i mean just look at
you know you go rewind 10 years ago i
mean think of how many states just
rejected
you know obamacare coming into their
states exactly and
that's that's why a lot of people do
believe obama
was the time that this division happened
but i'm like look i think it started
before that right you can reduce it
further and further look at al gore and
george w bush
yeah it was a supreme court appointment
of a president no matter what you
believe
there's half the country who believes
bush only became president because the
supreme court intervened right
now there's a lot of people who say no
no george bush won fair and square no no
the realities are divergent at that
point there's there's democrats who are
saying it was stolen it was stolen it
was stolen
and there you go yeah then you get eight
years of that then obama comes in
then you get people were accusing were
claiming it was stolen back then
like even even donald trump was saying
that you know romney and the interesting
thing about that is a lot of people tied
the supreme court fight of the 2000
election
to distracting our intelligence agencies
from
what al qaeda was up to in the lead
that's right
because there was no transition the
transition was so
it was so rocky it was delayed and it
was messed
up yeah between the clinton and the bush
administrations that a lot of people
look at that
as the one area where al qaeda basically
made its move
to enact uh to basically attack the
united states through 9 11.
i think that was where we saw a big
political split but an interesting
thing an interesting thing happened in
2008 with the economic crisis because we
had we had ben stewart here he was
talking about
strass how generational theory are you
familiar with that no i'm not
it's it's this theory that there are
four seasons the season lasts 20 years
you've got spring summer fall and winter
after
winter this great conflict this great
crisis comes a spring
where everything is really good the
economy blossoms and booms
then you have a summer where it's
maintained and people are happy then a
fall where things are getting shaky and
chaotic and then the winter again where
the chaos breaks out
so right now we are in the winter period
80 years ago the end of the last winter
was world war ii
80 years before that it was the civil
war 80 years before that
the revolutionary war and apparently
they've mapped out like all of these
things that
have happened every 80 years it's based
on generations are you familiar with
that saying
strong men make good times good good men
uh strong men
make good times good times make weak men
weak men make hard times
hard times make strong men it's similar
to that idea
that when you have a generation of
people who who fought through the
trenches
and many who didn't survive only the
strongest survive and come back
and create a flourishing strong society
of prosperity
their children inherit that world and
don't necessarily understand what it
took to create it
the next generation inherits a world
where they just feel entitled to it
which leads to chaos and collapse
interesting so it feels like
you know we're we're basically in this
period now
where we can expect i guess the the
the winter is here it's gonna get bad
and it's supposed to end around
2028 but my point was the point i wanted
to get to with 2008
was when we talk about when the
political divide started and when chaos
started to happen
they predicted in like 1990s when they
wrote this book called the fourth
turning
that in 2008 when boomers became
eligible for social security
the economic system was going to
collapse right perhaps
everything we know about what caused the
crisis mortgage-backed securities and
things like that
was actually just all the boomers now
demanding their entitlements
that didn't exist and figure out how to
cover it up
how not cover it up but like cover the
costs of rice
when you look at the m1 money supply
it's slowly stagnant over several
decades
2008 happens it increases by like by a
factor of 10 or whatever it's just like
spikes upward money creation is going up
rapidly
then the pandemic hits skyrockets
straight up
they change the way they report the
money stock mid pandemic and now no one
knows for sure
but you can see 2008 where the money
supply just goes boom and takes a sharp
turn upward
maybe mortgage-backed security crisis
they're giving out homes to everybody
and people couldn't pay for it
or maybe our financial system was broken
we knew it was broken
it was predicted that it was going to
break and then it broke
i've heard that this this theory that
they used covid as an excuse to print
because they had to print because
everything was falling apart it's it's
it's a
a conspiracy was it you was telling me
this someone basically i think it was
you who mentioned this they were saying
that
democrats uh uh made bad bets and
investments
that went sour and was going to
completely disrupt
pensions and 401ks and retirement plans
was it useful no
who told us that i don't remember
hearing that yeah i was hearing uh
there's a conspiracy theory that what
actually happened was
kovid's legit and we we had a pandemic
crisis
and we had 15 days to slow the spread
however the economic crisis was real
we're supposed to have you know they say
every 10 years is like an economic
downturn of some sort and we kind of
dodged that for some reason
i heard a conspiracy theory i'm not
saying it's true it's literally probably
not true
that democrats made bad bets with you
know unions made bad bets
they could you know they made bad
investments the investment soured
and then when covet hit they knew that
there was going to be a serious collapse
of retirement funds and people's 401ks
and things like that so they were like
we need a bailout
we saw all these blue states now this
this part is true you know cuomo for
instance being like new york needs money
and trump was like shove it too bad
run your state better now we get the 1.9
trillion dollar stimulus
and republicans are calling it a bailout
for blue states that are poorly managed
so i don't know i don't know i don't
know about i mean they have beer i mean
yeah they had the 2.2 trillion
stimulus a year ago right um and it's
covering
the i mean look new york's crumbling
they're they're the the metro for
instance the mta
they're struggling to repair it they're
not making enough money
as to how much it costs so you had that
whole situation with with aoc where
amazon was going to come in and bring
these 40 000 jobs potentially 30 billion
over 10 years they needed that money to
fix their train systems
that didn't it didn't happen and i i
guess
interestingly enough with the amount of
people that are probably leaving new
york because of the
the lockdowns i can imagine they're
probably going to be making way for
um you know a vacuum of sorts but i
wonder man
i mean bill de blasio said he's gonna
buy up these buildings
turn it into public housing i wonder if
the economy is just worse than we
realize
and they're not going to tell us because
panic would only make it worse right
well yeah obviously if they came out and
said
my fellow americans several large unions
with hundreds of thousands of members
put their money in dangerous places and
lost the retirements of millions of of
middle-class americans this is going to
result result in a ripple effect that
wipes out if
if they said something like that yeah
people would freak out oh hundred
percent
crash the banks remember exactly
remember what george w bush said after 9
11.
part how old are you i'm 33. all right
so you should remember this yeah
he said go buy stuff
he said you'll buy stuff well because
the
911 attack was in addition to being an
actual terrorist attack on the the
people it was an attack on our financial
center and what he was basically saying
was
if you want to help go out and buy
things to keep the economy moving
when when that attack happened and
people are panicking you get a natural
reaction from a lot of people to stock
up
store up save your money and bunker down
right and he was like no no the
machine's got to keep churning
you need to keep the machine going so we
generate taxes so we can pay for this
stuff so we can build new things
go buy stuff that's a scary prospect
because that can't last forever can it
right
so so i don't know exactly you know if
any conspiracies are true i would
actually argue they're probably not
that's why we call them conspiracies
but i will say you can look at the
crisis in 2008 the mass printing of
money
it was only a matter of time before we
were going to see that bubble burst it
could not be maintained do you remember
how much the 2008 bailout was for
it was like for 989 million dollars yeah
that was our billion
that was what was on the books i'm
reading an article here from that's too
small
this article from mit quotes a 2015
forbes article that says we've paid back
4.6 trillion of the 16.8 trillion that
we committed
to that bailout over i don't know how
many years 15 or 20 years or something
now this is forbes reporting that okay
um i don't
if if we secretly committed 16 trillion
in 2008 and we're still paying it back
maybe that's another explanation for why
they just flooded the market with 12
trillion
dollars dude the federal reserve the
fractional banking
fractional reserve system it is a stack
of cards it is literally a ponzi scheme
and it works because we have guns so at
a certain point
it's going to fall apart like you guys
understand how this how bank out banking
in this country works right fractional
reserve as far as i understand
is the fed the federal reserve will loan
a bank a million dollars the bank then
can loan out ninety percent of that
so they can loan out nine they need to
keep ten percent on reserve yeah but
they're not that
that loan is creating the money supply
so
when you when you give a hundred dollars
to a bank
they can then loan out ninety dollars
which is created on the books
and then expanding to another bank then
that other bank takes that 90 and can
loan out
81. no not necessarily they loan it to
you so they give you
so i put 100 bucks in in the bank of ian
then the bank of ian is able to give a
90 loan to the bank of circle
to to suraj as an individual sir i
should get my own bank you don't get
your own bank not yet but then you
deposit you're 90 bucks
you deposit your 90 bucks into the bank
of lydia
now lydia can loan out 90 whoa whoa this
guy's this sounds a little bit racist
talk about it well i don't got a bank
either oh i thought you just said
the federal reserve so so the point is
a bank gives an individual money the
individual puts it in a bank
that bank then loans out then an
individual loans puts it back into bank
so it's just basically a stack of cards
it's basically a game of hot potato
and where the debt keeps stacking up the
interest becomes impossible to pay
and then obama signs a massive stimulus
the money printing goes out of control
this was predictable a long time ago i
mean when did we go off the gold
standard that was the 1970s
70s yeah the 72 773 shock
you know what the issue there was it's
really really simple
if all four of us here in this room are
trading
you know one dollar between each other
so it's like i give in a dollar
in exchange for a high five then ian
gives siraj a dollar change for a high
five
the only way to get that high five is to
have the dollar and make it to you
so at one point i decided you know what
i don't want to have to give away a high
five to get that dollar
i want all the high fives for myself so
i tell all of you hey guys
i'm gonna manage the money printer don't
worry i'll make sure everything's good
and then when you guys are paying
attention i just print money for myself
i don't do any work
basically what happens is we're able to
fund all of these wars and all this
conflict
because the fed can print out money loan
it however they want without
contributing anything to society
we've got missing missing trillions of
dollars on the books or whatever from
the pentagon some some nonsense
we've not audited the fed we need we we
need to figure out how much money is
being printed who's it
who's it who it's going to and we don't
know at a certain point
if they can just snap their fingers and
create money on the books and we don't
understand the system
other people are exploiting it the house
of cards is gonna fall over yeah
that's it and i mean you you inspired me
to make a great idea i'm definitely
gonna start charging people for high
fives yes particularly
specifically kids you know if this is
another aspect of the situation that
bothers me is the oil economy because
because it's
so obvious that we're moving off an oil
economy under like a nuclear economy or
something
well people still have an aversion to
nuclear so i don't think that's gonna
right nuclear nuclear fission people are
afraid of the dirtiness
of corium meltdowns but like fusion or
like thorium reactors which also type of
nuclear which doesn't it isn't dirty
doesn't have corium byproduct so we're i
mean it's amazing tech
but there's this massive resistance
because if we go off oil
they can't extort the rest of the world
to use our dollar anymore
that i mean they bring up a valid point
i mean
think of how much oil runs our our
society
and moving off of that i mean that's why
there's such a huge push to obviously
not
go towards solar and wind it's because
it i mean not
i mean it's not it's not it's not it's
not it's efficient right
it's not efficient but also because the
entire push is obviously like
you know you got to focus on the coal
industry you got to focus on the oil and
gas industry
and you know we as a nation are very
conservative when it comes to changing
where we're getting that money like the
battery industry elon musk had to make a
company to build them
i know because the government wouldn't
do it well why should the government do
it anyway so that we can get us off oil
but they don't want us off well they
want us to keep buying tanks and oil to
keeping our base right
that's probably what i mean besides what
people think of elon musk's opinions
i mean elon musk is a in many ways he is
a trailblazer
because he is creating a renewable
source of energy
um but also commercializing space flight
and to the powers that be whatever that
may be
uh that's a threat because you know if
you if you exceed that power to elon
musk
one word bro china china
they're not going to stop using fossil
fuels right fossil fuels have an
excellent energy return on energy
invested
so we these good and noble
americans know that solar wind
geothermal hydra
you know tidal and hydro hydro you know
damn electricity all these things
are are great cleaner alternatives they
don't produce that
that that carbon emission but they don't
have a high enough return on the energy
investment in fact to build solar panels
requires a ton of oil
wind turbines as well plus we don't have
the batteries for them
so batteries yeah so we need a
continuous supply
so fusion is uh uh would be fantastic
nuclear power absolutely but you know
the activists don't want that either
yeah and i have to wonder
why that is because that can really make
us powerful
yeah i mean if someone figures out a way
to make a car run on dreams in starlight
it's over
oh yeah definitely because then we're
going to build spaceships and you know
let's do
rockets and lasers theoretically what
would happen if we went off the oil
economy
not that we stopped using it but then we
stopped relying on it tomorrow because
everyone had batteries and could
charge everything well we'd still have
to kill people uh overseas
right yeah we gotta we gotta make sure
that we're bombing those kids otherwise
these other rambunctious countries will
stop you know bending the knee to us
oh my god would china gain power or lose
power in the hegemony
if we get off the petro dollar china
just it's done they take over
because we couldn't extort our allies to
fight for us allies
who do you think we're extorting us
buying our oil are we talking about
everybody hates us
yeah here's how our allies hates
is britain buying our oil everybody
everybody here's how we're in that
exporter of oil
it's not just that if if let's say you
know you're the country of ian right
and i'm the united states oh do i get my
own country yeah
you're actually you're the the
federation the grand principality of the
federation of the list
yes the federation of the list it's
multiple countries you get multiple
countries excellent
so uh so we've got this this trade
federation over here we got the country
of ian and i'm the united states
okay i want oil it's really simple hey
fed
print me a trillion dollars so i can buy
oil they do i buy oil thanks guys for
all your hard work then ian says yo i
want oil too okay well if you want these
dollars you got to pay up
give me your money and i'll give you
some dollars i'll give you some of my
ian currency and you're like no no no
you need my currency to buy my oils
exactly you need to buy mike
it's not it's not mile it's your oil you
produced it in your country
and we force you to put on the
international market and if you want to
buy it back
you buy dollars from us first now your
trade federation same deal
it's the oil produced in your own
countries put on the international
market if you want some of it
you got to buy it in u.s dollars so
trade for me and i'll give you what i
think is fair
what ends up happening is con many
countries have to be net exporters
in order to keep this the strength of
their currency sound
so they can buy u.s dollars in order to
buy oil
even if it's produced by them or someone
else so
we know what happens to countries that
talk about getting off the petrodollar
muammar gaddafi he wanted to trade in
dinars
he died venezuela
venezuela saddam hussein he said why not
the euro
and he died it's a really weird
coincidence that happens
and then there's the cutter turkey
pipeline right the us wanted to build a
natural gas pipeline through
through syria and turkey into europe and
then
syria fell into civil war what a
coincidence yeah it's really funny
all that goes down isn't it that is yeah
so if
we stop using if if oil stops being
that like you know principal source of
energy then we don't have leverage over
these other countries fiscally yeah yeah
if fusion technology became
rampant like just just ubiquitous and
then all of a sudden
we go to you know this one country and
we're like yo you have been calling to
buy
dollars and oil from us and they're like
oh we got fusion we're good
really good example you guys ever
watched rick and you yeah yeah i know
exactly what you're talking about the
batteries the battery
right sounds like slavery with extra
steps yeah
exactly so so in in this show rick his
car breaks down
and his battery is a micro verse sort of
right
it's a micro verse yeah yeah so inside
it he's he's got this like little
universe where he tells all these people
to stay step on these like platforms
like a ddr
yeah dance dance revolution and it
generates electricity which he siphons
some off of
but then there's a scientist in that
universe who creates another microscopic
universe
and so basically what happens is rick
shows up and he's like yo
what's going on you're not making
electricity anymore and they're like
don't worry we figured it out we don't
need you anymore
so then he threatens to destroy their
universe unless they get back
to generating his power for him so the
u.s
if we get one of these smaller countries
some small middle eastern country
all of a sudden they they boom fusion
ignition we got
clean running energy it is it is it is
generating tons and tons of power and
they go
we don't need oil anymore well all of a
sudden the us is going to be like hey
we haven't heard from the ian country in
a little bit what's going on
don't they need dollars to buy oil so
they show up one day on a diplomatic
mission and they go
so so you guys uh is something wrong do
you need oil no nothing's wrong
everything's great we have fusion now
you have fusion yeah and then
and then he pulls out his buret
and then he goes problem solved guys
anybody else want to use fusion power
so look look i'm being a i'm being very
very facetious it's much more
complicated than that
it's not so simple it's not like the u.s
is a gigantic supervillain of a nation
but that is a big concern i do believe
if we ever actually reached fusion
ignition
the u.s would quickly use that to
reshape the world in its
favor i don't think the us is
purposefully holding back electrical
technologies
you know and it gets back to your point
about china because we're too
all of our interests all of our
politicians are basically sold out to
them
and there's no there's going to be no
concerted effort or
urgency to switch over to that because
again
the status quo is that oil runs
everything
if you want to win re-election you got
to continue making sure that the
oil industry is is well it's it's not
just that it's
the the so even if we perfect nuclear or
fusion
it's gonna take a long time a lot of
energy how much can we allocate in that
direction
the fear is china's building new coal
power plants they're absolutely
exploiting fossil fuels
and fossil fuels have a tremendously
high energy return on energy invested
so if the u.s shifts to renewable
energies or developing new power plants
we are at a disadvantage
china is rapidly expanding and growing
and it seems like we're losing that
fight anyway so at this point get the
fusion online baby do you think that
there's a concerted effort behind the
scenes for the united states and china
to divide the world
between them with a petro dollar economy
and they're letting us bicker about
human rights violations but they don't
really care because for them it's
business
no what do you mean china is about to
overtake the us
and the u.s is flailing and flopping
about but
they known we could never go to war
because of the nuclear conflict so
they're like that's not true
i mean well no that we should never go
to war i mean both governments you
should never go to war for any reason
and nobody ever really
wanted war i think there are some people
in the military
industrial complex once or like when
there's like a marauding force
slaughtering humans and you need to
intercede like isis
nukes will be fired if if the huns
nukes will be fired if war breaks right
so they don't want nobody
really wants that i don't think um but i
wonder if there's this business class
is using both these countries to
basically partition the globe
and that's why there hasn't been a move
on the human rights violations in the
uyghurs
and at all i don't think there's any
grand plan to partition the globe
that's just that's that's too much i
think the grand plan is ultimately
decoupling
uh you mentioned obviously this
aggression happened under any other
administration it has
but this would be the trajectory that
china would be going down regardless of
whether trump or biden was in office now
right um because the idea is that
right now a lot of these global
corporations they can
they can live off of on basically
selling a set of products just to the
chinese citizens
and then the set of products to the rest
of the world like they will actually
manufacture stuff differently
for two different audiences or two
different
groups that's that's true for a lot of
factories you know that right yeah like
when you go to walmart to buy a tv
you're getting a different tv than if
you buy it at best buy
people don't realize that no i mean it
so if you go
and there's a sony or like you know a
sony samsung tv at walmart
made with different materials in this
than the samsung tv same model different
materials
yeah that's my understanding you know
fact check man this one i could be wrong
well
i know google specifically tailors their
search algorithms for different
countries
different regions what do you mean if
you if you google search right now
anybody listening if you google search
auto repair are they gonna send you new
york auto repair
no they're gonna know exactly where you
are and they're gonna show you auto
repair i think they actually
give different tech like different
coding of their browsers and stuff like
they gave china a specific browser that
could be used
to track the people if i'm not mistaken
because
china wouldn't let google into the
country so they had to like build a
specifically
well they were working on what was that
thing called dragon something
and then they got google employees
revolted yeah dragonfly something
google employees revolted that uh google
was working with china so then google
backed off
google's response was well if we don't
go in and do this
someone else will at least then we'll
have some control it's like no you won't
if you go when these companies go to
china and they do
they have to open up a ccp wing of their
company they create like a division of
the chinese communist party in their
companies
so i'll tell you this if the nba if this
is true this is what we heard from china
uncensored
if the nba has a company a branch
operating in china
that would imply the chinese communist
party has influence in the nba
in the united states as well as in china
because they'll they'll go to them and
say
case in point when the nba banned the
phrase free hong kong on
customizable jerseys remember this yeah
i remember that that was in america
why because the nba in china the chinese
went to them and said don't allow people
in america to say free hong kong they
went
you got it buddy and so when you try to
type it in it'll give you an error
right look i mean dude we had uh
blizzard
the the gaming company they have the
game hearthstone one of the people
competing held up a sign that said free
hong kong
and so the player got suspended created
a huge controversy and then they're like
no no they got suspended because it was
political in general and we're not all
about that it's like oh dude we get it
it's because you have people you have a
branch in china and china told you
so we're already there china's communist
party has its tendrils across the globe
and whether anyone realizes it or not i
mean bill maher said it we lost
yeah we lost already i don't know i that
is very pessimistic of him to say that i
think that we're definitely losing the
military
game but like if it's a grand game of
civ and you can win with religion with
culture with
military with science i don't think
they're winning across the board they're
really
really totalitarian like the people hate
it
in china from what i can tell they're
just not allowed to say it
so that we got that working for him or
for us rather well you said something
about decoupling i wanted to just
yeah so decoupling means that you know
trade between the united states and
china
it's just you know it's the states
there's no more trade
and and so whatever relations that did
exist no longer exist
and so you basically would have to rely
on any manufacturing company that would
exist
uh say like uh say an apple or a or a uh
not disney but um let's just let's just
focus on apple for a second
if apple was manufacturing iphones in
china
and say the united states and china
decouple then all of a sudden
apple has to figure out how they're
going to manufacture their stuff
and be able to sell that over in the
united states and the rest of the world
and overnight that factory in china
becomes property of china exactly
and then they have the iphone factories
and they make iphones for themselves and
then we don't
yeah let's let's let's move to uh us
media real quick because i want to
advance the conversation
we have this tweet from glenn greenwald
which is going to blow everybody's minds
oh god
glenn tweeted if if if you're a critic
of the media you need to hear this
glenn greenwald tweeted read this
amazing section from judge silberman's
descent today
in a defamation case before the dc
circuit on how an increasingly
ideological
ideologically homogenized u s media is
not only threatening core free speech
values
but also the ability to be informed in
his dissent he wrote
it is well accepted that viewpoint
discrimination raises the specter that
the government may effectively
drive certain ideas or viewpoints from
the marketplace
but ideological homogeneity in the media
or in the channels of information
distribution risks rep risks repressing
certain ideas from the public
consciousness
just as surely as if access were
restricted by the government
to be sure there are few notable
exceptions to the democratic party
ideological control
fox news the new york post the wall
street journal's editorial page
it should be sobering for those
concerned about news bias
that these institutions are controlled
by a single man and his son
will a lone holdout remain in what is
otherwise a frighteningly
orthodox media culture after all there
are serious efforts to muzzle fox news
and although upstart mainly online
conservative networks have emerged in
recent years
i think it might go on no he so he
doesn't continue from there but i'll
read the next
uh the next section that glenn post he
said it should be born in the mind that
the first step taken by any potential
authoritarian or dictatorial regime
is to gain control of communications
particularly
particularly the delivery of news it is
fair to conclude therefore
that one party control of the press and
media is a threat to a viable democracy
it may even give rise to countervailing
extremism
the first amendment guarantees a free
press to foster a
vibrant trade and ideas but a biased
press can distort the marketplace
and when the media has proven its
willingness if not eagerness
to so distort it is a profound mistake
to stand by
unjustified legal rules that serve only
to enhance
the press's power absolutely amazing
to hear that but maybe it's too little
too late
but i'll tell you this it is absolutely
true how sobering
as judge silverman describes it that the
main
resistance to dem democratic orthodoxy
in the media
is murdoch so they said one really old
man
and his son is that what they're talking
about murdoch's son
lachlan lachlan yeah but isn't is
lachlan the one isn't isn't he woke or
something
yeah it's over everybody uh back it in
we're going home and uh welcome to your
new cult
i think we're incredibly resilient as
humans so if someone is speaking out
against it that means
that means we have a chance maybe so
it's a descent i mean is this is is this
too little too late i absolutely think
it is man
maybe maybe not maybe not maybe i'm look
there's a lot of people watching this
show right now
and this is not a you know what no no
i was going to say we're not ideological
here but we are absolutely ideologically
motivated here
classically liberal libertarian and
socially liberal values
represent the conversations we have here
for the most part there's a reason
it's really fascinating why leftists are
so hard to book
because they're they're they're at
authoritarian orthodoxy
it's very hard to speak uh safely
when you exist inside the confines of
their moral framework
that's why i've done numerous interviews
i did an interview in berkeley with this
woman
i'm standing in the street and i'm
filming some woman walks up and starts
talking to me and i'm holding my camera
i asked her some questions she answered
she gave horrible answers
five minutes later she walks up to me
and says delete the footage
no joke and i said i'm filming and you
walked up to me i'm not deleting it
and she was like no you have to i don't
give you permission and i was like i
don't need your permission
you're in public talking to me while i'm
filming i don't try to generate
controversy though so i blurt her face
i'm not trying to drag her i'm not
trying to get some random woman on the
street in trouble with the woke
but i did want to show what she had
basically said was
conservatives who get physically
attacked deserve it because of the way
they dress
she said there was a woman wearing a
maga hat she was asking for it
no joke no joke and so the issue there
is when you think about the moral
framework that exists in the minds of
these people when they say
women who are wearing certain clothes
aren't asking for it but when it comes
to trump supporters they are
it shows there's no actual principle
behind their moral framework other than
join the tribe or burn she wanted me to
delete the
delete the footage because her ideas
would get her cancelled
when people heard what she said you
can't stick your neck out
so many of these people they do their
shows the priests of the orthodoxy
the guests who have on this joe who are
more than happy to come and speak are
confident
in themselves in classically liberal
ideals of freedom of speech
and being and being honest expressing
themselves
and they're not scared about what the
woke mob is going to do to them well
that's i mean i think
you're that's an overstatement for me
since i have a very low self-esteem
which is why i got into media so that my
parents would know this who i am
there you go as as for most of these
journalists who work at mainstream
publications
um yeah you know that's interesting and
that's
that dissent you know i don't as as
ground breaking as that may be or
shattering as that may be
if that were say any other if there were
a celebrity that had like say a red pill
moment
it said something like that maybe okay
sarah silverman
yeah she came out recently and said i
don't want to be associated with either
party
because of the elitism and the
absolutely well uh what's her name
um oh the name is escape rose mcgowan
oh yeah definitely when she had her
moment that was big
that was huge especially in the in the
middle of the presidential election
she's like i don't
what the the accusations of tara reid
against uh then candidate joe biden
uh was enough from and the way it was
handled from
her charmed co-star alyssa milano yeah
that was enough for
her to be like i'm done that's it i want
to be optimistic
right now you know why they're not cool
people
who wants to be like them you know do
you want to be
one of these like easily agitated
panicky finicky
woke culture warriors working for one of
these publications
some people but it's remnants of the old
world right so the new york times has
prestige the great was it the gray lady
the paper
of record young people grow up
millennials
hearing great stories about the
prestigious the prestigious new york
times
it is my dream to be a times journalist
congratulations they hired you
and now you complain about tick-tockers
is that what you really thought you were
gonna be doing
or did you think you were gonna be like
meeting in a parking garage
and some like source walks up and he's
got a manila folder and he's like please
don't tell me when i was here otherwise
they'll kill me and you're like don't
worry
i'm gonna expose these criminals and uh
and then in reality you're like
so this 17 year old on tick tock you're
never going to believe this like as a
technical mention right but then like
one of his friends showed up
that's what the new york times has
become who wants to be that today
what young person who's actually on tick
tock is looking at what what what these
journalists at the new york times are
and going
i really want to be like that when i
grow up they're not doing that
so what's happening now is these these
these woke culture warriors of
culture warriors of cancel culture at
these big publications
are not cool and nobody wants to be like
them
young people especially you ever seen
the show the boys
oh yeah yeah of course no it's it's very
uh
i don't know why this conversation
reminds me of that but it's specifically
in the storyline of the first season
with starlight
who is trying to get into the seven of
vaught
she wants it's for those that aren't
familiar she's a she's a superhero
she wants to join the big superhero
organization right yeah so
and then she gets there and she realizes
obviously this is all a big
charade you know this is a corporate
entity
they don't care about like actually you
know saving people's lives they care
about the money flow
yeah and and so you know if you haven't
watched it i highly recommend it um
on the good show it is a good show um
which i got
off amazon prime because we're not
basically pumping up jeff bezos's
numbers but
but but it's it's it kind of shows that
classical trope of
you know don't meet your heroes right
she she really really wanted to be this
big hero joined this big organization
and then she realized it was actually
really awful everyone sucked
yeah and she didn't want to be there
anymore but i think it's i think but
that's like
but that is very much media today isn't
it but it's worse than that
no i know well i mean we're not a
fictional show and comparing
here's what i mean in the show the boys
the seven which is like the justice
league they're cool they're celebrities
everybody wants to be them they're in
the movies they got endorsement deals
who wants to go work for the daily beast
to write about i don't know cats or
something
stupid that's nonsensical and made up no
who wants to be that when they grow up
nobody
so so here's my point we've talked about
how
movies today going woke are becoming
like christian films used to be you know
like good
was it good flicks or whatever uh yeah
pure flicks pure flicks and everybody
everybody always laughs and then like
jokingly ribs me like hey don't make fun
of pure flicks
it's like watching those really like
really campy
religious versions of films with like
bible man or whatever and veggie tales
and stuff
as as these as look as the details as
the woke cult takes over hollywood
movies become preachy boring and
nonsensical
and uncool you got to watch have you
seen the new craft
no you will absolutely hate it you know
why
i don't care about the wokeness it's not
a good movie
it makes no sense the pacing is off i
have no idea what the message is
and it's just like nothing happens i
guess then a guy burst into flames or
something
the whole movie is a woke psa where they
just keep
giving off woke pot shots of like
they'll be walking on the street and
then one person
makes a comment about being trans and
you're like what does that have to do
with the movie like why is this dialogue
in the film
because they want to make sure you know
they're woke the wokeness is more
important the storyline
thus they've created something boring
that nobody wants to engage with
the movie will fail and then kids who
see will grow up thinking
that's not cool i don't want to be like
that if it's not cool it does inspire
youth
it won't it won't exist who are your
heroes
my heroes oh they're mostly rappers but
they're not really heroes
i don't know i mean i i actually no my
i have my heroes are like my dad my
grandpa like my legitimate heroes people
i think are like
through and through the greatest people
i know
and i don't the thing is and that's
exactly what it is
the never meet your heroes i don't have
any like
celebrity heroes but you said rappers i
like rappers
i love hip-hop and like their
inspirations and how i can like i love
this song
make music i love that my my my heroes
are dave grohl eddie better man it's
musicians but
it's what really is people yeah i know
they're real people but like
i you know that's the thing is like i'm
terrified of the
one you know the the potential of
meeting any of them because of how
yeah super flawed but they still inspire
you it's not
no oh bro who are your heroes
i don't have any heroes did you used to
never like growing up you never
nope watch people or no i'm too arrogant
i'm honest i'm not even kidding like i
would watch skate videos and they'll be
like a pro who's like the best in the
world
and am i sitting there going i can do
that my friends will be like shut up
you're not going to tre flip a 10
stairs oh you need a new friend oh yeah
and then i would go and throw myself
down the stairs and get hurt
well the reason i brought it up i was
not i was not that good but i was
certainly arrogant enough to think i was
my heroes were
are not these people that write these
pieces i don't think anyone think looks
up to these people and thinks i want to
be like that guy
no but they look at musicians they look
at like great performers
that's the real challenge in life and
and it's mostly a way of how they think
because you know musicians just
generally think a different way they see
sounds you know they they they can they
can compose
music they can create stuff out of thin
air
and it's and it just resonates with i
think
like it gives you chills and you hear it
like when you hit affect your song like
you ever get chills down your spine when
you hear that all the time music
affects us physiologically right like
you know the beats it's like
and it affects our brains in certain
ways it triggers emotions and we like
feeling good and we like
we like being made to feel so we like
the people who make us feel that way
but there's something interesting about
it i will say though we've already met
our heroes
because of twitter and they were all
awful
look i would never i don't look up to
actors and i don't care for actors i
think they're just actors and i've never
understood the obsession with like
celebrity i've always just been like i
don't care i don't care who cares
brittany shaved her head whatever
but now we get to actually meet these
people and we learned you know chris
evans for instance mark ruffalo they're
really nasty people
right chris evans is okay he's kind of
nasty mark ruffalo is one of the meanest
people i've ever i've ever
seen on the internet it's like he just
posts nasty things david cross also a
mean guy
and i'm surprised that how many
comedians and celebrities are just nasty
it's really messed up you look at joe
rogan's twitter what do you see
instagram instagram post of like him
eating steak and like his dog
yes and people like joe rogan you know
why because when you see him for who he
is you're like oh he seems like a cool
dude
but then you turn to like some of these
other comedians and movie the actors and
stuff
and they're just posting nasty things
screaming posting pictures of
decapitated trump heads and you're like
i don't want to be around that i mean
you know this is this is kind of why the
list exists
the list the list of people who should
have their phones taken people should
have their phones taken away because
it's designed to save people from
themselves
and the reason for that is because as
you mentioned people are really nasty on
it but if you don't enforce the list
then what does the list really do well
that's why i went independent tim oh
yeah
there's gonna be there's gonna be
there's gonna be like two guys in suits
showing up to like brian selter's house
knocking on the door and be like brian
it's
it's time and they take his phone from
him boom if i could do that i'd do that
right away
brian suther specifically i'm looking
for seed money anybody interested
yeah you're launching my twitter dms
you're launching a network the swaraj
yeah you like just went just went live
just went like solo yeah today today is
my final day big dude yeah
so maybe what you make will actually be
something inspirational to young people
and they'll be like when i grow up i
want to make a list of people should
have their phones taken away
well the idea is that i don't do it
forever and i have basically no but
you got to pass the list down i got to
pass a list on but no the whole thing is
like the captain america shield
but listen this is what i'm talking
about the list is important you know why
because it's funny it's hilarious and
people block you when you put them on
the list
for those that aren't familiar by the
way your guests from yesterday chris
schlichter he blocked me because i put
him on the list
nice all right so basically it works if
someone tweets something really dumb
and then if it qualifies for like you
should have your phone taken away for
tweeting that you'll tweet at them like
it's a meme post there's one
there was one i think the right hand
emojis right there was one of you as
consuela from family guy i think
one of you in a truck full of people
with a coyote driving the car yeah and
all the blue checks being taken away
it's funny people see it they laugh
there's going to be some young kid
who's seeing the world of politics he
sees someone like brian stelter from cnn
tweet something really dumb
like like tucker carlson is the new
donald trump or whatever did you put him
on the list for that one or no
um that's a team take honestly
right right but some kid will see that
post see everybody laughing and he'll
think
that's cool it makes people laugh it
exudes strength
and what that person posted was really
dumb yeah i don't want to be like the
person put on the list
i want to be the person naming people
who should be on the list
well it's interesting because i've
gotten criticisms like i'm a hall
monitor
or i'm you know i'm basically waging a
harassment campaign against people
which is obviously not true um
i've had people have meltdowns
about me putting them on the list like
this is the
i think of a few people from very early
on i'm talking like december 2019 when
this thing was still like in its
infancy the reason why it came the
reason why i started it was literally
one of those things where you know
kind of your recent twitter habits it's
just like it just came out of thin air
it was it was george conway dunking on
his wife kellyanne in a quick tweet
he's the lincoln project yeah the
lincoln project guy and it was like one
of those things were like oh no you
should never do that in public
give me that phone george that is taking
your phone and give me that phone man
um and he is the first person i put at
number one
and he doesn't have a blue check he's
not verified
but like everybody thinks it's because
there's everybody oh
the list comes for all but like there's
a higher standard to me if you're not
verified because literally anybody could
just post whatever you want if you're
not verified if you're verified there's
you know obviously like a standard that
you you you have to live well yeah you
got the endorsement of twitter
exactly yeah you know so i think some of
the value of your work too is like you
mentioned
the resonation that you feel from a
musician that vibration
also you put yourself on camera and your
voice so you're creating resonance
literal physical resonance it's so
different than just writing
being behind a typing thing and putting
words on the internet
like that's how you really affect people
in my opinion i think this media this
internet video media is so
powerful i prefer video more in writing
every day of the week
that was my strength i mean i was a
commentary video right there
i i mean sorry commentary video editor i
do edit videos but like
they had writer in there i just you know
because i did write from time to time
but like it was
if i it turned out in probably like the
last like three years
of me being at the examiner is that if i
wrote anything it would all
already be a video so like whatever you
see in an article is really just like
the script that i had in
in the video so it's it is a
better way of reaching people because
most people don't like to read
i mean that's just kind of the way the
world people have very low attention
attention spans
well they can start on a podcast and
then go work on something else exactly
you can apply
podcasts have become so effective that's
why audiobooks have become so
so effective is that you can literally
multitask as you're listening to this
stuff
and if you have to rewind you can rewind
who can you know no one cares yeah
you're free to do it but people play
video games into podcasts they go to
work that's very tough to do i don't
know how
you just pause it when they say
something really cool and then go rewind
it and watch
i mean i've done that you know it's like
you're making breakfast or whatever you
turn on a podcast and you said make
breakfast yeah so i'm watching tv
but i almost always twitch stream now
when i play video games i don't know if
that should probably just
game offline for a bit that it's going
to be really interesting the future
because i see a lot of people like
everybody has a twitch channel
and they'll get like seven live viewers
or whatever and i'm like who are these
like seven
people who are watching instead of
playing and doing the stream themselves
and what happens when everyone does
and then everyone is streaming them
playing a game and no one's watching a
lot of people just have it on in the
background
a lot of people yeah so it's and you
hear people saying like so i'm gonna go
steal this car and then light this
hooker on fire
sometimes i'll play the game heroes of
the storm it's a moba
multiplayer online battle arena game and
it sometimes it's just so stressful that
i just want to watch other people play
it
so i don't have to worry about winning
or losing i can just enjoy the process
i mean i i'm not very competitive at all
which means i suck but
i do enjoy just like the interaction and
the and the fun that you get with
like if if you play with a community of
people like just like the
enjoyment and the jokes and laughter
that you have with them um
yeah some people just take gaming way
too seriously and that's probably why uh
um everybody wants to like crack down on
gamers true
what have you been streaming lately um i
do i do play the
car call the uh cold war or black ops
cold war uh goes to tsushima
i'm trying to get into more of these uh
samurai games i hear nioh as well as
sakura or
really money yeah that's a souls type
game yeah i do
i am playing demon souls on ps5 very
difficult game
we we actually have a streaming rig for
gaming we're setting up oh
nice there's a lot of expansion on the
way the first thing we have to do
is create the new timcast.com website
then we've got to create the new brand
website for all verticals
gaming mystery podcasts and all that
stuff but uh it'll it'll it'll happen
when it happens i guess we're gonna be
hiring and just gotta
grow organically it's not super easy to
just do outright but
it's common but how about we go over to
super chats
yeah to see what everyone else has to
say my friends if you are listening and
you have not already smashed that like
button
you should because it is greatly
appreciated and go to timcast.com become
a member for
exclusive members only segments and i'll
everybody actually we got a super chat
here i'll just read it
will again you know for some reason
youtube always blocks the name of the
first super chat so i can't see it
but they ask will we see the chicken
city this weekend
we did actually it's not a big city it's
just like four little chicken houses
we have it built it is 99 done we just
have to add one more security layer
it's this big fenced off area and then
we've like dug into the ground so that
there's
it's it's pretty secure but the issue is
we wanted to go get chickens and it's
still
a little too cold so we were supposed to
be able to bring the chickens out to the
chicken city
this week i think we're going to wait
because they're still a little small and
still a little cold out
colder than we expected it was going to
be so it might be another week but maybe
we will finally film something and i
always keep saying that and just like
never happens
so uh fingers crossed it's there it's a
potemkin village
a ghost a chicken ghost town there's no
chickens in it i'm sure it's not a
chicken microverse yeah
microverse yeah and uh we're gonna we're
gonna power powering all the electricity
in this
studio the chickens are very young you
just mentioned that the chickens are
like
kind of babies yeah yeah yeah adolescent
they need uh uh
they're good to go now to be on their
own outside like they're big enough
but uh you know i i the guy we bought
him from was like you might lose some
but
you know you'll probably be fine and i
was like we'll just keep them inside for
another week just to be safe right yeah
they should be fine though in the
temperature yeah right now but uh
we think we want to be safe but uh uh
maybe i'll just we'll film some of them
doing chicken stuff and show you what we
got going on
all right let's see we got mr pool
doesn't call on me says tim
how does it feel to go from super white
and not cared about to suddenly top of
the oppressed charts and everyone loves
you
it's uh it's what i've always dreamed of
you know so so
as you know like asian people were
called white for the longest time yeah
and so i'm i'm double white basically
i'm double weight too yeah you see
there you go and then but but now asians
are an oppressed group again
hell yeah so let's go uh
somebody got a people got attacked and
now they're yeah the atlanta shooting
did you know
yeah yeah i've heard about it but yeah
that's all it was
well it was a couple of
there was a big march against white
nationalism
to help support an asian man who was
attacked by a black guy
uh-huh in new york and then and then a
few other
there was a grandma an asian grandma who
was uh was attacked oh and she beat the
guy with a stick
yeah beat the crap out of them that's
weird i don't know what the full story
is on that one though yeah
i really hope somebody got some video
with that this big protest in new york i
bring it up because that was one of the
big
you know things we saw of like thousands
of people marching against white
nationalism
which was like a weird thing to march
against but uh it did generate attention
for the hate crimes against asians
so now we had that uh that incident that
occurred in atlanta
where this guy was like a sex addict and
so he was going to he was accusing these
shops of being like you know rub off
shacks or whatever
and then he killed a bunch of people
yeah he killed eight people yeah so at
least six of them were asian yeah okay
so he wasn't from what i heard he wasn't
targeting uh anyway
depends on what you read that's the
thing is that we don't
again the investigation as it plays out
we will see because i don't know
anything i don't know much about this
guy
and i don't know if he had an animus
towards asians it's possible
wait wait for the facts to come in and
that i mean the unfortunate thing is
you know as we were talking about how
there's like two different americans
uh two different americas with competing
information this is one of those things
where there's competing information
about
it yeah so yeah well look what we know
about what the guy claims
is that he was a sex addict and then you
get the media that mostly the left media
trying to claim it doesn't matter what
he says and then you have that tweet
from this woman who said
she was like just a rule or something
you don't get to decide if you're racist
it's your actions that everyone else
gets to decide if you're racist or not
so i was like then i've decided based on
your actions you're racist that makes
you racist
so and if you deny it that's proof it
also reminds me
you remember in like 2015 there was a
parking dispute in north carolina and an
apartment complex
and one neighbor a white man shot and
killed three
muslim americans i don't remember that
no young people they're like
all in their late teens early 20s yeah
that sucks
and everyone said yeah this is
islamophobic i think i was on the
bandwagon of saying yeah that's straight
up the anti-muslim attack
um and we i don't even know if we still
know the answer whether he actually had
animus
towards these towards muslims i think
it was one that it was yeah it was like
it was a it was a brutal murder
and it was horrific and this guy is now
i think he's
serving life in prison but uh it was one
of those things where like
is it a hate crime the thing
the evidence of what we saw at the time
did not really add up but the fact that
he murdered three muslim
uh obviously two of two were women
in hijab uh in the head covering um
it was that was a another one of those
types of debates right they say
correlation is not causation right
i think i think look a crime's a crime
why should we criminalize motivation
because then we're trying to reach oh i
mean
because the hate crime the the idea like
because hate crime
i guess carries a more severe penalty
yeah yeah but like if someone commits
murder they commit murder
you know what i mean well i i get that
but it's you know there is
malice and intent and so then we should
have okay so if you commit a murder
and there's like no known motivation
it's just murder but if you commit
murder to steal money then it's
larcenal murder or financial murder and
then if you commit murder because of the
clothes they were wearing that it's
fashion murder
and then we'll have different levels of
punishment based on what you were
feeling before you murdered the person
uh i mean that there is politically
inspired i mean if they are talking
about the fashion stuff i mean who kills
i mean they're i mean he was wearing a
vest
investor out of style well so i mean
think about all the people that get
murdered for their shoes
here's the train absolutely so here's
the issue you know in dc if you see a
guy in a maga hat
and you beat him it's a hate crime i
don't know
if he doesn't have the hat on in dc in
dc
if you punch a guy and said it's because
he was wearing a maga hat you committed
a hate criminal
if you say it's because of it if well
this is the problem with hate crimes
like if there's a dude walking down the
street wearing a maga hat and someone
punches him that person can be charged
with the hate crime because political
class
is a protected politics as a protected
class of dc
for obvious reasons the the issue i take
with it is that we're trying to figure
out people's in
people's like internal morals and
motivations
instead of looking at them and saying he
punched a guy well intent
does mean a lot especially in our
criminal justice system
because if i mean that how do you how do
you decipher between self-defense and
murder
okay so if some guy robs him if a guy
robs a bank
and there's two guys they both rob a
bank one guy did it because he wants to
buy
you know an infinity pool you can't
really afford that with what you get out
of a bank but he wants to rob a bank
because he wants you know brand new
shoes
the other guy does it because he's
starving to death okay fine the guy who
is starving he gets a free pass because
that was starving
robbery versus greed robbery you see the
point i understand
all we know is someone went in and said
i'm robbing this bank when we
when we get into the hate crime arena
we're trying to read people's minds to
determine what was the cause of the
crime in the first place
instead of just universally saying dude
if you punch someone you go to jail
i think they've actually decriminalized
thievery of food in another country do
you remember hearing about that oh yeah
san francisco
might as well call california another
country seriously it might have been
another country also but that's in san
francisco
yeah oh no there's one where they're
poor and starving and they steal like
i think in virginia and like michigan
the cops can't pull you over
for like expired plates or blowing a
stop sign or failing a turn signal or
something like that smelling like weed
yeah yeah yeah so it's like you don't
signal and you blow a stop sign in the
cop can't point over
all right there you go so anyway look
i understand the idea of hate crimes i'm
just like
if you hit someone with a pipe that's
aggravated assault i think they're like
trying to measure intent leads to
thought crime and like the thought
police
partly it's it's you're not going to
read someone's mind
like so there's no way to fully know
what somebody's intent is and so here's
in their heart here's the problem
i don't i don't care you know why this
guy
in in atlanta did what he did i care
that he did it
i care that innocent people lost their
lives
and he had he they're now trying to mind
read you got one
one outlet being like it's clearly
racist then the other outlet saying no
no no he was addicted to sex no no he
was racist
even though he doesn't say it we know
and it's like
can you give me the name of the people
he killed the people he killed can we
give us can we get a ceremony for the
victims
it was days before we realized who any
of these people were because the media
was too busy arguing about whether or
not the guy was racist or not
well there's there is the aspect of like
prevention
in the future so if you want to avoid
something like this happening again
you need to understand their motivations
in order to make sure
whatever the warning signs were for this
particular shooter
uh and suspected murderer uh is that
this doesn't happen to another person i
feel like you guys are both making
extremely good points right now it's
kind of weird it's kind of blowing my
mind
i don't know how you well that's a first
for me how do you how do you
how do you stop somebody from committing
you know from from hating how do you
stop someone from hating it's a natural
human experience people hate things well
like if he killed because he was
because he was starving or if he killed
because he hated the person's
race then you know like what problem do
i need to address
right good point how do we stop the hate
either
either well as a for with like family i
mean that's a deep conversation
yeah how do you stop someone from hating
someone else um
re-education camps maybe oh yeah yeah
yeah jesus
neuron wait banned speech oh yeah if
they can't hear the hateful ideas they
can't become hateful right it works so
well
i know you know here here this is wait
wait if they can express the hate or
rest of them that way they can't act out
on it
this is something that i actually
learned um very early on
growing up and the one thing that helped
break down
stereotypes was traveling because i
lived abroad
i lived in lahore pakistan for six years
and through there i was able to travel
to different parts of asia
africa europe and
that was definitely an eye-opening
experience
and while not everyone is in a position
where they could do that um
i mean that would be for me that is how
just literally interacting with
different parts of your community
honestly because you don't
know how other people opera
you'll find that more people are just
like you if they are
part of another community and you find
that you have more in common with them
once you build that little consensus
you can see them as human beings right
on well let's read some more super chats
zabruci willis says man it's weird
seeing your old videos and comparing
them to where you guys are now
american dream baby yeah it's just uh
it's just
progression and goals you see this is
the advantage of skateboarding
growing up where you're constantly
learning a new trick every day i would
go out i would be like what's the new
thing i'm going to do today
and before you realize it actually i'll
i'll rewind
the path the journey of a thousand miles
begins with a single step
so you know how i started this all this
stuff on youtube
i had a gopro 4 and i would put it on
top of my monitor and press record
and then i would talk for 10 minutes
then i would stop it and i would upload
it and that was
it yeah me too and then eventually i was
like i can make this a little bit longer
and add some some
um some other stuff to it i can add like
articles and quotes
and then start doing that and then i
started a new channel where i started
doing more videos
then i got a better camera got a sony a
thousand frames it was super
super nice all of a sudden the audio was
a little bit better and then
eventually i was like i should get an
actual microphone i should get an actual
camera
and then from that i learned how to
build everything i learned what
you know how to set up a podcast studio
and then within like a year and a half i
was
having a podcast recording setup yeah
and then once we started uh i think it
wasn't until we started irl last year
that actually switched to these
microphones i love these mics
i used to use high quality cinema grade
shotgun mics
so they'll be mounted on top of the
camera in front of me he's the worst i
know these are
these are beautiful oh i thought you
said they're like literally hanging out
in front of the camera
and like they're projecting is that what
it is like a shotgun microphone
yeah it creates a cone yeah yeah that's
what i would use but these were like
movie grade the kind that
they would use for capturing audio like
an outdoor scene in a movie like really
expensive
and uh these are these are substantially
cheaper
and in a lot of ways better these mics
we use now they don't pick up audio from
everyone else it's really just you and
that's why i need to switch because when
it was just me recording i had this
really expensive cinemagrade microphone
and it was great these are a lot cheaper
these are the
sm7b by the way everybody is incredible
all right let's read a little bit more
adrian sutton says
come on tim you said i am excited for a
biden presidency i will be laughing and
smiling the entire time what happened
man
um i don't want to laugh at biden for
falling down stairs
and it is uh perhaps i was a little too
optimistic
on the course we were going to be moving
forward with
i will say when biden won i was laughing
that was hilarious
and uh that's what i was like if biden
wins i'll laugh
as for the biden presidency there
actually is a lot you can laugh about
but it is getting really dark with the
escalation of between china
and so perhaps it is it is just a cold
splash of water in the face
i thought oh you know it's going to be
fine whatever and now we're kind of
starting to see like it's actually a
little darker than we realized or at
least that i realized
by the way too much faith in the man i
guess uh
how how how ironic is it that
the biden administration is through the
daily beast report i'm sure
i'm sure some of you have seen it when
they
they were basically sandbagging and
sidelining their
members of their administration for
smoking weed
oh yeah
[Music]
apparently then kamala she's she's yeah
we knew it we knew it
apparently they said how many of you
smoked pot don't worry we won't punish
you if you tell us
and then we're like i did you're fired
that's funny
that's hilarious yeah so the fact that
kamala is like yeah
smoked weed i listen to this new dog in
tupac
and boom you're fired get out of here so
we got it we got a great one here from
evil zombie hamster he says for that
rant on monday
waited until payday for the super chat
everyone should listen to that rant
uh if you guys are familiar with
whatever that rant is then make a clip
of it and uh feel free to upload it to
social media whatever
basically uh i was talking to somebody
he was making a point about how
me and carl benjamin changed and then i
went on like a three-minute rant about
how
people like were cowardly and gave up on
the political fight
and have you know given into censorship
because they're scared and blah blah
blah
all right who see joe gang says first
time super chatted also became a member
last month you guys are the truth keep
it the good work
we will try what is up man oh yeah we're
gonna keep doing it rock on
sir youtube says everyone here should
check out the latest on sky coin
interview with adam
stokes and the dev the coin and skywire
project is wildly ambitious and aims to
build a kind of decentralized parallel
internet of sorts
tons of crazy political info there too
weird sounds cool
job b says that video of biden stumbling
is suspicious
there are six servicemen standing there
and no one moves no one is talking about
it
yeah when biden tripped i guess some
people expect the servicemen to run up
and try and help him
but it was literally only like two or
three seconds yeah he looked like he
recovered
you know when i'm like running upstairs
sometimes i like you know hop
up and down you know i trip all the time
every single time i do that
and it looked like bynum was doing that
too yeah and for
in some ways you know he was trying to
like hop up
yeah he was trying to pull a suraj and
you know that's right he jacked his left
shoulder
and cnn ran the segment during the pr
trump presidency saying is trump
scared of stairs they said does he have
bathmaphobia
where he's unreasonably scared of stairs
and i'm like maybe he just knows that if
he slips they'll make fun of him so he's
very cautious to like
be on his toes and then there's this one
clip where they did mock him because he
walks up a runway and then he
wobbles to the right and they're like
haha trump almost fell
but then we actually look at the photo
trump was nowhere near falling and it
looks like he was just screwing around
like he went whoo well what was the
graduation ceremony last year that was
it the army
army military academy he was walking
down the ramp and everyone was like
what's wrong with president trump yeah
the man's got a physical disease he's
not he's not fit for office
he was wearing dress shoes and like
going slow so he didn't slip
yeah i mean you have i mean over the
course of the trump presidency you have
stories from
uh brian stelter or others who you know
there was a letter from like 700
different psychologists trying to
diagnose uh president trump with a
mental illness
from afar i mean like the the stuff
never stops i am interested to see how
this fallout
compares because i'm already seeing
stories from say like the new york times
saying oh you know
president president bind's 100 fine have
you seen the movie hoaxed from mike
cernovich
i have not there's this really really
great point in it where
they show a clip from i think it's a 60
minutes interview with scott pelley
and pauly is criticizing i did see the
scott pelley in it so
he criticizes certificate she's like you
claim that hillary clinton is sick
and he goes he's like no i cited a
medical a medical doctor he goes well
how can that doctor
you know uh uh know that he's sick and
he makes
he's like well how do you know she's not
sick and he goes because the camp that
the clinton campaign told us
and he was why do you trust the clinton
campaign and the dude literally fumbles
and drops his glasses
because cernovich made a really good
point
when they were criticizing trump saying
trump's mentally ill or whatever because
the doctor said so it was a fact
when when they did when conservatives
did the exact same thing to hillary they
were like oh you're lying and making it
up
we get it to double standard all right
soberman wasn't off man
we got the gc geek army saying tim
awesome to see my habibi in the compound
what what does habibi mean habibi means
like it's arabic for like my
my friend my dear my love it's a term of
endearment
zinke user for
my friends i had a friend who used to
say woody all the time it's like a
southern term for a male friend
okay yeah yeah i guess it's woody and
shoddy
yeah female
1985 says we are not in a democracy
never have been the times article about
this
cabal should have made that very clear
they just made sure the rules were on
their side so the results went their way
instead of the way people wanted i think
the the best way to describe what
happened is
the it's fortification of the election
the rules are there you can see what the
rules are it's like
it's the matrix man right the agents in
the matrix
can move off fast and crazy right but
they follow rules
so when neo finally figures it out he
learns how to move off fast and crazy
like they do boom
that's it so when they fortify an
election
they're basically like the agents they
make the rules the way they are
and a lot of people just don't know how
to use them by the way one of the very
first list memes was when i
was i was neo in that last scene of the
first matrix where he's
he stops the bullets yeah it's literally
me with the pink
i love it all right lee 4466 says saw
your video on the ford plant today i
work there and i voted for trump and i'm
not the only one
despite popular belief there's a lot of
right-leaning union members
especially with trump then i know
the curly afro says china has to keep
tibet for their water supply
xinjiang for oil and south china sea for
blue water navy
to solidify their rule they have two of
the three
yeah by the way you guys been up on
march madness negative
no but i did see that woman who was
screaming about the weightlifting room
you see that one i did see that
that was that that was that was a messed
up thing that the ncaa did
they gave the women this tiny little
rack with like tiny little weights
and they said that the ncaa's uh excuse
they said there wasn't enough space
she takes a video there's there's an
entire like conference room
not conference room i'm sorry like
they're like in the convention center
there's plenty of space it's just i
think matt walsh called it out and he
said
one is entertaining and one is not oh my
god or something like that
well so listen there there is an issue
uh i knew i know uh a bunch of women who
com
well this is a while ago now i haven't
you know hung out the x games in
a decade or so but i've actually been to
the uh the x games a couple times as
like an all-access team manager friend
of these athletes
i knew a couple of the female pros
people don't go to those events
so what had happened was early on they
were paying the women like 10 percent of
what the men were getting paid
and their they they straight up told the
the female athletes
it's because we don't sell tickets you
know you're like you're getting a lot of
money but people don't show up to watch
you skate so what do we do
they ended up winning the right to equal
pay because they were like that's your
problem and that's true because women's
tennis does well
they were they're like if you can't
market this properly
then why is it on us we're the ones
performing we're the ones you know
coming here to put on the show for you
and then you can't sell tickets
sounds like you got to fire your
marketing guy yeah that was actually the
best argument i've ever heard for it
yeah so when people
talk about the wnba and they're like
yeah well nobody wants to show up
because it's boring i'm like nah
it's marketing it's marketing yeah if
you've got if
i don't care you know women the u.s
women's uh you miss
the u.s women's national team better
than the men's team that may maybe maybe
people say it's better than the
more people watch the the matches of the
the soc the national soccer team
um because they've won four world cups
right right it's so dominant and it's a
matter of marketing
it is so like i think about going to a
music venue
look i've gone to see shows from people
i've seen sold out shows from people who
are not the greatest singers in the
world
because they're good it's good marketing
they know how to how to get you
entertained
how to entertain you and make you have a
good time and so i'm not gonna blame
you know the person who's doing their
job i'm gonna blame the person who's not
doing their job
granted i understand what people are
saying i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
blame ohio state for
completely messing up my bracket i chose
you
to win in both of my brackets and this
is how you treat me
they were supposed to be terrible i had
the ohio michigan ohio state michigan in
the final
all right completely blew it someone's
calling me out nadia shall worry no more
says tim your pov on u.s future against
china
has been pretty negative it's very
contagious and has gotten me down and
nervous
you have so much influence so say it
with me i would rather die on my feet
than buy
chinese keep your chin up guys here's
the problem you don't know what's coming
from there
and not only that you might buy
something that's made in america and not
realize that
components of it are made in china right
assembled in america you'll see a lot of
now
yeah assembled here components yeah
well i do think we have to do better to
get more stuff made in america that's
for sure
so i'd love to make a graphing company
here i've talked about it before
yeah we'll keep that in in our minds um
graphene solid-state
batteries definitely sodium okay
hennessy drew says tim you only ever
mentioned the patriot that died in
portland you are forgetting the other
guy in denver
oh that guy in denver he was killed by
that security guard who was like a
progressive activist but he was there
working as like foe security and he
wasn't
legally allowed to be that was the
denver guy right yeah
track media only says they don't want
peaceful divorce if they ever
changed then it would be to consolidate
and then later come for the other half
dems want it all and communism is all
about give your stuff to others
i don't think the establishment
democrats are communists i think
they're short-term gain individuals
they're like
they're going to extract and exploit
whatever they can but there are
communists
on the far left who are willing to it
who like are sitting in wait letting the
democrats burn everything
burn everything to the ground so that
they can come and pick up the scraps and
then get their communism you say so
short term is a great way of looking at
it's like with this hate crimes against
the asian people
like it's like a knee-jerk reaction
something happens and then they make
these sweeping
i don't know who decided they're on the
the
minority list or whatever the heck this
list is but it's like
a little something happens and then they
immediately change
it's like you gotta think of the big the
big picture it should have never been
i don't know ew says ian the government
didn't create the oil industry the
entrepreneur did
stop looking at government to answers
they have none also oil isn't going any
going away for a while
you need it for jets trains semis and
also petrochemicals
will always exist that's definitely
right yeah but the government broke up
standard oil
i mean if we had let rockefeller create
an oil empire
that would have been way worse than
where we're at right now
well c'est la vie brandon maguire says
if i were china
i would just wait until the left has
taken our guns away the inexperienced
military
would be no match for ours add in all of
us proud american gun owners and
millions of veterans
see ya later mommy
spike dude says have any of you guys
played the metal gear series
i think hideo kojima was secretly a
prophet
yeah there was something about metal
gear solid people were talking about
weren't they i don't know
something in it i like was prophetic i
played the first metal gear
for nintendo oh yeah for nintendo
yep oh no no i play i play them the
original metal gear i don't know
the nes yeah yeah i play that on ps1 and
ps2
metal gear solid no no you're solid yeah
yeah
god those are licking omg puppies says
the key to fusion is high temperature
super conducting magnets
check out an excellent video mit's
pathway to fusion energy by zach hartwig
great overview of the science and
engineering of nuclear fusion
very cool pandabang says that fiat
currency is a good thing
the gold standard was bad the situation
at the border is good and we should be
grateful for immigrants
january 6 was the worst worse than 2020.
uh
at ian free the graphene
free the graphene you're right
uh let's see tessera says i lived next
to
tyndall afb and saw the f-35 in flight
six of them hovered about 250 feet over
the highway they made no sound
even underneath people in panama city
will testify they have active camo
we've all seen it wow what what is that
like crazy
camo jets or something or what i'll look
that up f-35
secret weapons
paul luckett says sorry tim it's getting
difficult to watch your content it's all
doom and gloom the battle is over give
up and lose hope
this message gets people's down it gets
people down depression is already too
high
we need to try to spread more hope well
i do try to be somewhat optimistic in
that these
these woke people are really destroying
themselves now and
the more fun funny people seem to be
doing better better and better
so maybe it's just you know the night is
always darkest before the dawn and
things are starting to turn around
maybe maybe we'll we'll pull out of this
by 2024 and things will improve
dylan percher says ian is correct china
may be ahead for now
but so was germany and japan in the
beginning decoupling is correct as well
look into peter zahan's work he lays it
out as for apple phones
manufacturer can be moved back and 3d
printing will be cheap
ah there you go turk longwell says that
guy in his lists ephem
sir who made you the official list maker
love the show
love the show all always on point smash
the like button and spin it
smash that like button your hatred gives
me one
michael nguyen says all i'm hearing from
greenwald is it's time to end new york
times v sullivan in order to smack the
news media in the mouth hard enough to
stagger them
because they lie yeah i don't know i i
might agree with that
it's tough times via sullivan's at the
standard where
news media is allowed to they're allowed
to lie about someone
if they didn't know it was a lie so i
can't measure if they knew or not
it's really difficult and so these
lawsuits often get smacked down so
here's the way it works if there's a guy
named like john smith and he's a
carpenter
and the new york times says that he john
smith you know
punched a puppy in the face he can sue
them for defamation
and it will like immediately go through
because he's not a public figure they
need to prove
like it doesn't matter if they knew it
or not they lied about him
if they write a story saying siraj
punched a puppy they can say well we
genuinely thought it was true so
and you can't sue them even if you're
like show me the proof
it doesn't matter really yeah that's a
problem they're called anti-slap laws
strategic lawsuit against public
participation so long as you have a
reasonable
belief that something is true you can
essentially defame people so they use
very clever ways to do it
they'll say like while siraj is uh
did not punch the puppy he's known to
push puppy punching
and then you're like what does that mean
to push puppy punch what does that mean
push
and then they'll be like oh when he was
seven he you know he he pushed a
photograph of a dog getting punched
uh yeah or they'll just say a source
told us it's actually really funny
you bring that up because of my my dog
ernie
and uh the habibi punched him no i never
punched him
i love him it's just it's
it's just because i had he has his own
twitter account and yes i i
created it with the intention of him
running for president in 2020 and his
his general platform was to deport me
and all of the problems in the in
the united states would be resolved and
so basically everyone's been rooting for
him to deport me
and uh basically any time that like i
don't give him a treat it's like
violence against
so here's here's here
you pushed your dog this platform well
so here's what the media can do
if you have an account for your dog you
want you said you say you want to run
for president
he did run for president okay so we know
you're joking
right but the media can write something
like you know the
the the story was amplified by siraj
hashmi
kama who posts unhinged rants about dogs
being president
clearly a sign of mental distress they
can do that
i mean there's something wrong with me
they could they could even literally say
that so the issue is there's often
settlements if you watch like project
veritas you'll see he always has the
retracto
usually that's because these people bend
the knee immediately
because they know if you get past a
motion to dismiss
you go to discovery and depositions and
that's when these organizations panic
you'll see so so this is this is news
too veritas just got passed a motion to
dismiss the new york times i think it
was all right
which means these writers have to sit in
a room under under oath
i believe under penalty of perjury and
tell the truth
so it's really amazing what happens
because they immediately
it's remarkable watch these videos that
veritas has put out and you will laugh
like they'll write something like you
know james o'keefe once did a backflip
off a building or whatever
or punched a dog and they'll be sitting
there sitting there in the room and
under deposition and go
no he never punched the dog why do you
write that he did um i was wrong
and you're just like wow they know
they're lying and they get caught for it
and they're forced to settle
wow they're forced to apologize or
whatever because i know they're going to
lose
jonathan galterini says have you noticed
how the media is slowly turning on biden
it feels like they are dipping their
toes in the water on bashing biden why
i think they care more about money than
anything else capitalism may cure the
virus they created
what if this happens what if jonathan is
correct
joe biden is going to start getting
slammed in the media he's it's already
starting
we had msnbc criticizing him because he
ordered
border patrol not to allow press access
to these facilities and migrant
facilities
what happens if the media realizes
there's money to be made oh they're
coming forward if they criticize biden
yep
and then all of a sudden we get four
years of biden bad
oh no and you get you get a crumbling
economy crumbling infrastructure a
failing president
a a raucous china and a media
capitalizing joe bike off joe biden
claiming he sucks
and then trump comes back ooh
yeah if that were to happen all of it at
the same time
with desantis as vp then trump would
probably i think i think trump is
running regardless
if trump doesn't run it is desantis yes
i think whoever runs
between those two is going to win 100
definitely
you so you think no matter what 2024 is
republican yeah
it's a lot of things that can happen
from now until then i know but
this is what really bothers me but i
also thought biden was going to win
i i as soon as trump won um
knowing biden didn't run in 2016. um
i thought whatever happened in in 2016
that
i i knew that trump was going to win
like a week before the actual election
but afterwards if biden had been in that
i thought that
there might have been a chance that he
actually would have won so in 20 so
like 2017 was like if by the wins by the
runs in 2020 he's gonna win
the important thing to understand about
shows like this and what i hate about
the internet is
there's context and then there's like
temporal context or contemporary context
and the way i
described it to you earlier is if i said
something like
oh ian came to me and said i
am thirsty but i don't like gatorade
people could then take that statement
where i said i am thirsty but i don't
like gatorade
and take it out of context to attribute
that quote to me that's so crazy
that's out of context but there's
something called there's something else
there's contemporary context
where i could be reading a news article
from the new york times that said
gatorade put you know i i i won't use an
actual brand the new york times
might read an article saying popular
soft drink accidentally drops
rat in beverage and then i go wow
i'm never drinking beverage again that's
disgusting i think this is disgusting
this drink is gross and then people will
take that quote and say tim hates this
brand
omitting the contemporary context the
time when a story came out so there's a
good example of this
i said something about i don't trust the
new york times and i was referring to a
singular story
i was talking about a couple different
stories and i was like oh yeah well the
new york post said this
the new york times said this i don't
trust the new york times
i was referring to one story that gets
taken by a bunch of leftists to claim
that tim poole thinks new york times can
i
can i jump in on that because this is
really interesting that's happened
online you know
vox journalist rupar yeah we post a
bunch of videos and stuff
yeah um he is now being accused of
taking
captain jay baker i believe that's his
name from atlanta
um and taking out the what was it the
conceptual context
by basically contemporary or
contemporary i'm sorry yeah contemporary
context
to make it look like uh the captain was
saying
that the suspect uh the atlanta shooting
suspect was having a really bad day
what he was doing was that he was
actually saying that this is what the
suspect's
explanation was of his own actions
saying that he well that's just general
context yeah
okay all right so he said he had a
really bad day
he was quoting the guy he was quoting
what what the suspect's explanation was
these people are evil man
and rupaul framed it as if that was what
the captain said fooled me
he got fired the captain got forced out
of his job i i that i thought the
captain said that me too
so i mean man you gotta you gotta be
really careful when you watch these
videos because
people are so quick so quickly this
stuff gets
spread we got an important one here mr
brownstone says stimi hit
and tim cast sub locked in member only
content is worth
every penny keep up the good the great
work and guests cheers good sir and crew
dude we got a full hour with james
o'keefe at timcast.com
we need to create a better library
system so we have a new website coming
soon
but if you go to the members only
content you can just keep loading more
and we got an hour with james we got
an hour we got full episodes yeah with
kim and a bunch of people
talking talking stuff you're not going
to hear any words good stuff i just want
to say mr brownstone
uh best song off appetite for
destruction shout out great name
that's my opinion all right we'll do a
couple more here if you haven't already
smash the like button before you take
off but we'll read some more
j.a says habibi bro here who is also a
member of timcast.com and a twitch sub
of suraj
ohio state and michigan state were both
overrated go blue
there you go what's up abibi
mike gref says things we can all agree
on
never trust the media politicians or the
chinese government
can we all rally behind this not a
facebook apparently we can't
i mean maybe just not at face value
never who looks at nancy pelosi and goes
i trust that face
a bunch of people oh why a lot of people
trust nancy pelosi man
why i don't i there's like you know when
people ask me like you name a good
politician i'm like rand paul
yeah i don't know you know that guy
that's like that
he gets a really high score for me and
there's a couple others i might
shout out josh holly well josh hawley's
on the list but he's closer to the
bottom no offense to josh hawley ted
cruz
i think thomas massey yeah rand paul and
then
you know josh hawley's all right matt
gates and ted cruz are all right
um i give i give praise to rokhana for
standing up to pelosi in a few instances
but i disagree with him a lot of
political political stuff
tulsi gabriel was fantastic yeah she
left politics right right that says
everything can you
are there any politicians you want to
give a shout out to you that are genuine
and trustworthy oh man that's really
good
question right look i
have a reserved um
distaste for politicians i realize that
they're all human
and they all have you know they're all
set to do a job and they all have
different pressures that
influence them so i am never going to
praise a politician just
outright for you know being good or
being bad i'm sorry or criticizing them
when they're bad
um i will just call them out when i see
them
mess up what do you think about rand
paul
he's a wild card you think so yeah
because he was v
he he during the trump era he wasn't
really himself
you think yeah i don't i i he got on the
trumpy lean
yeah it was very unran paul like
and i'll tell you this when i when i say
i praise rand paul it's because on a
scale of 1 to 100
he's he's at 51. he's like over the
halfway mark
by like the smallest which is like the
best rating you'd ever give a politician
ever
yeah like he's a little bit better than
like okay
whereas like all the other politicians
are like you're kind of bad yeah you're
all kind of bad and you're and some are
worse
horrible yeah so i i like josh hawley
but i i'm he's
he's yeah
you know i begrudgingly say i like josh
hawley because there's some things he's
done that i like
but that's a that's the problem there's
like there's personality and then
there's policy
how do you separate that right i like
their promises oh yeah no i was just
gonna say like some policies are good
but the personality is horrible yeah
some personalities are good but the
policies are horrible like you just
can't
it's very hard to liking that
is different than liking their
personality we got a very important
super chat from uh
mujahed khabi oh that's that's that's
this is a question for suraj
habibi he is my co-host that's my
co-host
why is your love for jen rubin undying
essentially you live
100.
uh love you jay all right we got uh
drunk surfer says shout out to louie
gohmert
louie's alright too yeah he's cool it's
it's easy to point out certain
republicans that i think are good but i
disagree with him a lot of policy
it's hard to find democrats that i think
are good
and i disagree with most of them on
policy
all right uh galandro glade says you
should get fleccas on your show
we genuinely we we want to we will at
some point yeah he's busy
oh it's interesting paul crane says from
about from a bottom of my heart tim you
alone completely destroyed my
conservatism i was born into
i feel like a free man thank you sir oh
oh i have no idea
yeah yeah is that good or bad all right
everybody let's see
last super chat ronnie floyd says great
podcast like always
y'all each need your own shirts like an
animated tim smashing the like button
and lids pushing the buttons on in the
corner yeah
well we do have the diamond hands
gorilla shirt pinned in the chat
right now you can get yours it is an
homage to the wall street vets crew
because we have a gorilla shirt and then
they have the gorilla meme
so we like i decided to make a shirt and
i thought people would think it was
funny
and a lot of people really like it we've
sold a ton of them already so thank you
all to everybody
if you have not already you must smash
the like button
i'm surprised you know we we end up
getting you know like 30 to 40
000 people watching it and every episode
we only get around like 10 000 likes and
it's just
come on you know everybody knew just
press that like button yeah
if you don't like it it's literally
islamophobia oh there you go
well now you have to like it literally
otherwise you're the wrong ideology
exactly also go to teamcast.com look i
don't know if we're ever going to get
this this weekend stuff up because
things on the week the weekends tend to
be chaotic
uh true i started taking weekends off so
i could do other kinds of work and also
have some just like
to wake up when i need to wake up and
then we've been doing like interviews
and stuff so we wanted to do range
footage then luke ended up leaving so we
didn't go to the range or we did we
didn't have anybody to film it we didn't
really have a plan
and then we wanted to do the chicken
city thing last time but then we got the
chickens and they were like
it's too cold and we we realized a
security issue with chicken city so
we're like okay we need to re-up
security and
and we basically had to like bury some
stuff to prevent you know the
the jerks from trying to dig in to kill
the chickens so we'll try our best
but uh thank you all so much for hanging
out for for those who are members for
being members
and like i said you can go to
timcast.com click shop get your diamond
hands gorilla shirt
you can follow me on all social media at
tim cast my other youtube channels are
youtube.com
timcast youtube.comcastnews this show is
live monday to friday at 8pm so we will
be back monday
siraj you want to shout anything out now
that you're a free and independent free
man you can follow me on twitter me i
don't know
i don't expect you know how to spell
that it's probably in the video
description
you can also follow my new venture at
habibi bros
uh it's habibi underscore bros and then
if you
like our stuff subscribe to us on
patreon at patreon.com forward slash
habibi bros that's where all our content
is going to be right now
until they announce something in the
future gosh you can always follow me at
ian crossland.net i really appreciate
you guys for coming i love the the chats
and the super chats it was really
really epic interaction thanks jay for
giving that nice donation i love you
jase
yeah i'd rather not come from the
company account 69
well it's good promotion i suppose yeah
it's true 100 percent
sorry no you're good you're good i just
had one final thought because we were
talking about the censorship
and this judge's descent and i just
wanted to say that this has occurred to
me that
um social media is censoring much better
than the government ever could have
dreamed of
nicholas work who used to work for the
libertarian party commented earlier
today on twitter something about how
cancel culture is basically like just um
cultural accountability
obviously not true and this judge's
dissent points that out perfectly
because it doesn't matter that it's not
the government it's still a huge issue
anyway i'm sarah patchell it's on
twitter and mine so you can follow me
there
we are going to have a new website up
very soon
hopefully next week but i'm not entirely
sure our our optimistic uh
view is by mid next week maybe late next
week
it may get delayed but it looks way
better there's going to be an easier way
to sign up there's going to be
alternate payment processing stuff like
we're we're revamping everything
basically
here's i'll put it simply for you
everybody came in and smashed the like
button as soon as they did we just
magically had the funds i'm kidding
when we set up timcast.com and we got a
bunch of members
that membership gave us the resources to
hire a real dev team
to you know like a large group a big
company to redesign and everything so we
we use that you know based website as
the launching point
everything's going to get better we're
going to have a blog
section where people can write articles
for us and we're going to do news
stories and things like that
and then we're going to be launching a
brand website that has the video game
channel the
video games themselves we have a video
game in the works it's going to be a lot
of fun
we have a card game and we're just going
to be doing a lot of fun culture stuff
so that is all with your support you
guys rock thank you so much for hanging
out
and we'll see you all at timcast.com or
we'll see you monday at 8 pm live on
this channel bye guys
you